Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast at [inaudible].
Just checking again of just checking in on,
you know,
just seeing how your week is going.
This is,
this is a,
it's a hard week.
Okay.
Coming off the holiday vacation,
you know,
at some point on your vacation,
a certain thought pops into your head and I'm not talking about walking out the
front door and just abandoning your family,
you know,
and not even because you don't like your family.
Maybe it's a relative that's just their cackle,
you know,
when it's just making your eardrums just vibrate in a certain way that,
that it wakes up that part of your brain that just doesn't give a fuck.
You know,
the Party of brain that's sociopath's are always it.
You know what I mean?
Just the wrong cackle can open that door for a minute and then your brain starts
going like,
what if we just got up and left
and what came back later?
And no,
no dude left like left.
Not like left or right.
I mean leave left.
Gone.
What if you did that right.
Um,
plus also it's the beginning of a new year.
There's a lot of hope in the air.
Okay.
Um,
chance for new things and if you'd like to keep that hope,
ah,
you probably shouldn't watch the news because you know,
I've been fucking working my ass off already.
And uh,
I was like,
wow,
I got really nothing to talk about.
Let me take a glance at the news.
Good Lord.
I just googled news there,
this whole article on Donald Trump about how he never wanted to become president
and then just some of the quotes they have,
it's like,
where did you get that quote?
You know something about Donald Trump being like,
yeah,
I'm not going to win this fucking thing.
And then he finds out,
he made it to the next level and he just showed it,
looked ahead and see and allegedly said,
this is so fucked up.
It's like,
who knew that he said that?
And I don't,
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
And then I'm watching all this stuff and Palestine and that the whole fucking
thing.
It's just about money.
That's all it is.
It's about fucking money.
Okay.
You don't want,
sometimes I wonder if everybody in the world,
right.
It has to be a weird game to play it right with all these fucking rich people
just squeeze in the fucking life out of everybody.
Pitting everybody against everybody.
If he just,
if everybody in the world just was just like,
well,
what do you,
what do you want?
Huh?
What?
What exactly is that?
The tea she's take it.
Does that make you happy?
I don't think,
I don't even think they could enjoy it.
They could have the biggest fucking house on the biggest hail and the biggest
side of town.
All of that fucking ric flair shit.
Right with minus the humor.
They could have all of that.
And the fact that everybody beneath him wasn't miserable on some level.
I don't honestly think that they could enjoy it.
Um,
who is a built,
give me one.
I don't know.
I looked at the news for 10 minutes,
such,
that's what I felt.
That's why I don't watch it because it makes me think things like that.
All right.
I don't like fucking seeing people around the world crying.
I don't know.
You know,
I gotta commend people who actually try and pay attention.
Maybe that's why they,
they just blame one side or the other.
Cause other than that,
if you just sort of try to look at it in an impartial way,
you're just like,
we're just the fuck are we doing to each other.
It's really depressing.
So let's get out of this.
Okay.
You know,
I'm,
I solve any fucking problems.
Here was kitten.
Whoa,
this podcast supposed to be an escape.
Um,
anybody watched?
Uh,
the Sally is Boston Celtics Force to Cleveland Cavaliers.
I had a bad feeling about this one.
I was like that white dude and put tune like,
man,
I got a bad thing.
Um,
before he charged up for shit this time I thought Lebron was going to come in
and I was like,
Ooh,
boy.
Oh boy.
I was the thought Isaiah Thomas' plan,
but he wasn't playing and love went down.
But I mean,
he played most of the game,
but uh,
so that's the game.
We should have one.
And not only did we win,
we won by 20.
And you know what that means?
Come April.
It doesn't mean shit,
doesn't mean shit.
Maybe if we'd go down to one game and it comes down to home court,
we went by one game.
Maybe it means that,
but other than that,
it's just a winter,
January.
But,
um,
I dunno,
when I look at the Cavs,
I'm just like,
all right,
these guys,
when they get to the fucking playoffs,
they get enough grizzled vets and then they got superman playing for him.
They got jr Smith was the Shit Isaiah,
we all know what the fuck he could do.
They got fucking Jae Crowder,
right?
I mean,
they,
and then they got love.
I mean,
that's a hell of a fucking team.
So,
but when I look at the Celtics,
I just see that when next,
you know what I mean?
It's like Cleveland is that old movie star that still fucking selling more
tickets than the young buck coming up.
But that person knows,
they know,
right.
They know that they're Burt Reynolds and uh,
I don't know what Tom Cruise,
I don't know who to pick next.
And when Burt Reynolds and then it was Tom Selleck,
which was weird when I was growing up every fucking like movie star Dude,
we had to be a guy's guy with that fucking mustache.
So it went from Burt Reynolds,
who I think established the look
right?
Danny had Tom Selleck.
Denny had that Guy Played Matt Houston.
And then somewhere in there the mustache went away.
But there was like a seven to eight year period with that mustache,
you know,
and the black curly hair,
you had to have that shit.
You know all these fucking groups that think all you gotta do is just be a white
guy and the door opens.
No,
they're looking for that fucking dope.
You had to be that white dude with the jet black hair and that fucking mustache.
And if you,
you had to be the Marlboro man.
He looked like me.
My fucking role models growing up.
Who was all be Ron Howard,
Ralph mouth burning for room two 22.
None of them got any pussy.
You know what I mean?
Rob Ritchie was fucking had a longterm fucking relationship and it's the prime
of his life.
Well,
Lori Beth,
who,
what are you doing this weekend?
Meanwhile?
Fonz,
he's having a fucking threesome over by the jukebox.
Everybody's looking together way.
Why?
Because he had that hair.
He had that fucking,
you had the right colored hair.
That's how it works.
Um,
anyways,
I don't mean what the fuck I'm talking.
What the fuck was I just talking about?
But we're,
are we talking about basketball here?
Fuck.
Am I talking about Fonzie now?
Basketball.
So that was a big,
that was a big one for us.
Big Idea one for us,
but you know who's getting him?
You could beat the cavs and January anyway,
but then you went far as avid cub,
April,
a bad ad way.
The big boys [inaudible] one layer at a time.
All at bullshit.
Right?
But whenever it was a fun game to watch and uh,
considering I took my lady to a Celtics game when I went home for Christmas,
uh,
she's kind of watching now.
I got her watching.
It's fucking incredible.
Yeah,
she's not rabid yet.
She's not rabid.
I got to get him into the day in,
day out,
fucking soap opera of it.
You know what I mean?
The way she got me into,
uh,
one is that fucking show that she watches hip hop or love,
something like that.
Love and hip hop.
That's what it is.
I fucking watch that show.
I can actually sorta handle that show
other than there's just one chick on there who just,
I swear to God,
I don't know what she just looks like.
She looks like an evil man.
You know what I mean?
And I don't mean like a,
like sinister,
I literally,
I literally mean like possessed by the devil.
They do this fucking weird thing on all reality shows now.
I think they kind of stopped,
but these were older episodes.
Do you know that thing they do where they,
they put those,
those cat eyes,
whatever that filter,
whatever the fuck that proper technology,
technological term is.
When they shoot those people talking right on the reality shows they do that
thing where they give them like three highlights in their fucking high.
Then it looks like they're starting to turn into something but they never do.
You know what I mean?
Um,
they kind of do that.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
I never feel wider though when I watched like when I watch love and hip hop
though,
you know what I mean?
Cause I have no idea what the fuck's going on.
I can't tell who's a good rapper,
who is it?
But I will tell you this,
like most white people,
if you change your fucking we've,
I can't stay I the amount of times I'm like,
that's the same woman because they'll cut back and forth
and the woman will go from jet black hair to fucking blonde hair or,
or black with purple and then change the color of a fucking eyes,
you know,
as white as I am.
I guess that's a completely different person.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
which is why no white person should ever be on a jury.
Right.
If there's somebody black involved,
I feel just from just from my own personal experience how fucking dumb I am.
I just made that blanket statement on how the entire just judicial system should
work in this country.
How about those fucking Boston Bro?
It's Huh?
They fucking want again.
They're like seven.
Oh one,
two in their last nine.
What did Jack Ed would say?
And then he said like 16,
three and two when the last 21 they're on fire right now.
Okay.
They were on fire when it doesn't count.
No.
Um,
you know the deal,
but it's good.
It's great that they're playing with at the plane and I haven't been able to
watch them as much.
I know that they're playing the panthers,
so I'm watching that game.
So,
uh,
cause I'm in the bowl teams right now.
So now rather than,
I usually what I did was I would watch almost every Bruins game and then I would
watch,
you know,
important Celtics games or whatever.
But,
uh,
now I kind of,
I've gotten into both of them cause they're both young teams playing fucking
great.
And I got a kid and just the way it's been working with the dad responsibilities
is every time the fucking Bruins have a game,
I got to do some dad stuff,
which of course comes first.
No disrespect to my beloved Bruins.
Okay.
Um,
but anyways,
I'm going to watch,
what is it tomorrow night?
Yeah,
game comes on at five.
Aldi.
I can watch that.
I'll definitely watch that.
Um,
all right,
so that's it.
I think I don't have anything else to talk about.
Oh,
by the way.
All right.
I want to thank that person that fucking said that I was an alcoholic and that I
should be a friend of bill w whatever the fuck it,
which just sounds like another Bush,
you know,
it's going to be running for office,
um,
later on sitting down to South America with the fucking land that he bought that
sits on a fucking
aquifer painting.
Okay.
I would I,
the amount of money I would pay t to just be in George W's had,
you know,
not Obama said
yeah,
Obama just sounds like he would be,
he would sound like the way you talk,
all blah blah blah,
blah blah.
What the fuck he was talking about,
you know?
Okay.
But I dunno if somebody wd always fascinated me.
They would just be sitting there
like,
what the fuck was that?
What the fuck was that?
Did I really do that shit?
You know,
I don't sell about that guy.
Always looking at that.
Looks like the kind of guy who would take summer school with,
you know,
Obama is like the kiss ass
fucking
raises hand when you forgot to assign homework,
you wouldn't really is,
is I don't like smart people.
You know,
I have a lot of weird things.
I don't know.
I don't look a certain type.
I don't like book smart people.
Uh,
just cause I see this is all petty shit just cause I'm not good at it.
And uh,
and the older I've gotten,
I realized somewhere along the line I don't like beautiful women.
Obviously.
They're fun to look at,
obviously,
like my wife is fucking gorgeous.
I think she's gorgeous.
But generally speaking,
I don't like beautiful women.
I just don't like it.
And it's for very simple reason.
They did their fucking rude
ditch.
They're just fucking rude.
They just don't have just,
just common politeness I guess on some level because if they're even remotely
polite,
maybe a guy's like,
oh,
she wants it.
And then they can't get rid of them.
But uh,
ditches,
fucking rude.
I can't tell you the amount of fucking times at the end of my show,
right.
Someone will come back,
some guy will come back,
you know,
a couple of guys and they got like,
three or four beautiful women with them,
whatever.
And they come back to say thank you for the show and the fucking women,
I swear to God ditches,
they're always bored.
Never say thank you.
And I always end up feeling like,
just why Swi always going to be like,
why didn't you two guys just come back here with,
just say,
obviously I don't,
didn't enjoy the show,
or they were upset that they didn't get to meet Oprah.
I don't know what I mean.
This is all,
I got a bald Red Ed and dad's jumps around like a fucking monkey or more.
Do you want from me?
I could sweaty to dig.
They come back.
They don't even say thanks even if you didn't like the shell.
Right.
Okay.
Like say I went to one of their fucking show,
some fashion show where they walked down the fucking runway.
Like they're all pissed off,
you know?
I don't know why God knows they haven't bought a drink and the whole fucking
life,
I don't know what they're so fucking mad about.
Even if I didn't enjoy the show,
even though I thought what they were wearing was ridiculous when I went back,
I would be nice enough to be like,
Hey,
you know?
Yeah.
I liked the way.
When you walk,
how your legs cross over and funny beats.
You did a heck of a job,
you know you didn't,
you didn't fall over and no shoes.
I could never do that.
I wouldn't lease tab to,
to common decency to say that or I wouldn't go back there.
Okay.
Bored shitless.
I'm bored shitless.
I,
I dunno,
I always fought,
have always fight the urge to be like,
what do you do?
What the fuck do you do other than sit there and look at amazing,
what the fuck did you just sit there?
Hmm.
How many times a day does a beautiful woman's sy just out of boredom?
You know what I mean?
I just feel like you could take them to an SNL taping and they would be excited
until like,
I dunno,
somewhere in the middle of it,
you know,
when the sketch was about them,
they would just start to get upset.
This is really bad.
I shouldn't say they're all like that,
but just generally,
generally speaking,
um,
I dunno,
that's just something that happened to me recently.
Just struck me as funny and I was,
I called up via afterwards and I was just going off on it and she was laughing
her ass.
Off I go.
They just,
why are they so fucking rude?
I just don't understand it.
Go fucking go hang out with some beautiful people.
I'm sorry.
A lovely Jesus Christ.
What the fuck do you want from me?
I didn't ask you to come back here.
I just kept thinking of that Richard Pryor bit.
When he went to the fucking White House,
they invited him to the White House and then they treated them like shit and his
wife's trying to calm him down.
He's in the back room,
you said asked to come to this motherfucker.
It was one of my favorite lines.
He have a,
had I done that has to come to this motherfucker.
MMM.
Anyways,
I don't even what I'm talking about.
You know what?
I got my first advertising of the year.
Holy Shit.
I'll tell you I was dying on the vine there for a minute.
MMM.
Maybe cause I say dumb shit like I don't like beautiful women.
I have no beautiful women by 40% of our product.
Ah,
right.
Sorry,
that was my password.
All right.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh look who's back everybody.
Toto toto beyond these no more sweaty balls.
Badu to toe.
Brds beyond these.
Take the bitch to the mall by everything in the fucking stores.
She don't care cause she's a hoe.
She's looking for someone with a shiny here car.
This is why I don't watch reality TV.
And it's really my big complaint,
uh,
when Nia watches reality television is because I have major issues with fucking
women that I had been working on for a long fucking time.
And you know,
if you've noticed in my last specials,
I really have stayed away from,
you know,
the epic levels that I've gone to at some point to the point I watched him now
like what the fuck is wrong with me?
Um,
but now she's got me watching this reality show and it's just every fucking
thing,
every paranoia that I have about them,
it's just shown in.
It's,
it's just constant throughout the whole fucking thing.
MMM.
You don't,
it'd be like,
it'd be like if,
if you were a you a woman,
you had issues with men and every night you had to come to my house and watch
fucking Monday night raw or some sports radio show we listened to like the
dumbest of the dumb guys.
Sorry to bug their secondary.
You know what?
I would've done it on first.
Just having to listen to that like that would somehow,
anyways,
let's get back to the underwear here.
All me on these heavy buddy.
You know,
he wasn't thinking about anyway,
we know you were thinking about the gym membership for the New Year.
Wait a second.
This is me on these coffee.
All of a sudden they're fucking doing horoscopes.
We know you're thinking about the gym membership for the New Year.
Why don't you commit to comfort and sign up for a me undies membership,
fresh new undies or socks delivered to your door every day.
Choose from bold,
classic or adventure is prince switch between membership plans or skip a month
at anytime may on I southern most comfortable fucking underwear your will you'll
ever own.
Made from sustainably sourced naturally soft fabric that is three times softer
than cotton.
I love her.
They don't say modal modal.
They don't say that anymore.
I want to say it's because of me.
They finally got sick of trying to teach me how to say it.
Alright,
offer must read right now.
Get me up me and he says an exclusive offer for Jess,
my listeners and whoever else they advertise with until January 20th get 20% off
your membership and free shipping.
That's 20% off and already discounted membership and be undies is so sure you
will love their underwear.
They even offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
You order a pair and if you don't love your first pair,
get a full refund.
I would love to listen to their fucking complaint line.
Oh listen man,
I love the colors.
All right.
Okay.
I got camouflage cause I've got anal leakage and I thought to being a brown in
it to hide the fucking skid marks.
Okay,
become a member today for the best membership you will ever sign up for me on
these four with me undies.com/ [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] become a member today and start enjoying all the perks of having a
be on these membership and start wearing the best underwear of your life.
It changed my life ever day according to the copy.
It's time to let me undies change yours.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr right now,
B,
u,
r,
r.
O and we got one other,
he likes hallux.
You know there are a ton of online mattress retailers popping up these days.
All with a one.
So you think the heroin epidemics bad,
these fucking mattress retailers that just,
they're everywhere.
All with the one size fits all solution to a better sleep.
It's like the music man,
except with mattresses.
Well guess what?
One size fits all doesn't work.
Alex Sleep,
he looks,
offers something that doesn't exist anywhere else.
A mattress personalized to your unique preferences and a sleeping style that
won't set you back.
Thousands of dollars.
Go to helix,
sleep.com/board take their simple two to three minute sleep quiz.
They'll build a custom mattress that we'll even though be the best thing he ever
slept on for couples.
They even personalize each side of the mattress,
which we all know is the beginning of the end of the relationship.
All right,
for guys in the prime of their life that sleep on their stomach and wake up with
a hard on,
they even have a little banana shaped dividend there so you can continue to
sleep.
Everyone from Gq to cosmopolitan to try to New York Times are all talking about
headaches,
sleep and once you try it out you're going to Ah,
you got to know why.
Your custom mattress arrives direct to your door in a week and shipping is
completely free.
Tried for a and a hundred nights.
If you don't love it,
they'll pick it up.
Gross.
Picking up with what
fucking hazmat suit with a beekeeper suit over it and their refund you in full.
Oh Man.
If I had that job,
I would be cursing out that BW fucking animal.
I would given me so much shit.
Why don't you just fucking just tight onto the top of your car,
drive by skid row,
and they just cut the rope and let it fly into those fucking people you know,
you know,
site to be.
If a mattress landed on your tent when she got over,
the fact that the building is sleeping next to and collapse on you.
You know,
I'm talking a mattress,
not a box spring.
I don't want anybody to get hurt here.
He just have it fall down.
And then you just put your tent back together,
you know,
right on top of the mattress.
That'd be the shit,
right?
I mean,
you know,
other than that,
you live in outside.
Uh,
go to Hank helix,
sleep.com/pro right now,
and you get $50 towards your custom metric sense.
Helic sleep.com/for $50 off your order.
He likes sleep.com/birth ah,
right.
There you'd go.
All right,
so
these Aa guys wrote in on Monday,
you know,
with their smarmy,
we really care about you.
You know,
trying to say that I was a fucking alcoholic.
What?
I want to tell you something right now.
Friends of Bill W it is July 3rd right?
By the time you hear it's going to be July 4th and aloe already gone.
Three A's in a fucking row.
All right?
It was on the wagon.
431 days jumped off for six glorious fucking days.
Glorious days.
Oh,
it tasted delicious.
Right?
And I'm right back on it.
You know,
God Damn Aa people date,
they don't like that I could do that.
That I can dip in and dip out.
They don't like that.
They think I'm gonna lose my whole life.
And then in,
in the bottle,
I'm not,
and I'm stopping right now,
you know,
just out of pure vanity,
I just like fucking
not just being a bloated booze bag.
That's why you stopped to begin with.
I didn't stop for the right reasons.
I stopped because I didn't want to be a fat fuck.
That's why I stopped.
You know?
I swear to God,
I want to go to a fucking AA meeting.
I want to go down.
I'm going to listen to those stories again.
It's fucking,
stories are incredible.
You know,
I can't imagine if quint terantin and went to a fucking Aa meeting,
the movie that that man would right afterwards.
All he's gotta do is listen to their stories.
Throw some karate in there and get Jamie Foxx.
I mean that's how do you not watch that fucking movie and then put it in 70
millimeter like he did his last one,
the hateful eight and anybody else see the hateful eight and 70 millimeter and
that fucking stage coach came into this with the whole orchestra piece.
It was incredible.
One of any writers do that Shit,
man.
You got to feel bad how he's just going down there.
All those people fucking fucked up their lives.
The misery that they've gone through and you're going down there pretending
you're one of them just so you can get some good dialogue for your fucking
script and maybe sell something to see.
Wife will quit calling you a loser.
You know,
I don't know if this happens.
I have no idea.
I don't know why I'm acting like this is fucking happening.
I'm not saying it's happening,
but you know,
would surprise me.
Right.
You know,
it's really surprising me is,
is
the fact that I still have another four and a half fucking minutes to go.
And this is one of the few times that I don't have anything to fucking say.
I got one for you.
You know what I did today?
I did Jones.
He's Jukebox on K,
Los Steve Jones from the sex pistols.
I've always been a fan of his,
his radio program.
It's on from 12 to two in the afternoon.
He plays whatever he wants.
Sometimes he picks up the guitar and just makes up a song.
He always has great guests and all that type of stuff.
But I'm an old man,
so I,
I,
I never knew where it was.
I would always find it.
And then I,
you know,
I don't know how to set the fucking buttons in my radio,
at least the back in the day.
So I,
I don't know the,
he had a,
he has a great one.
And then the guy from the e street band,
little Stevie,
what does his little Stevie's garage,
they just amazing fucking Djs.
And their knowledge of music is incredible.
And the fact that are actually you listening to base you listening to a fucking
rock star playing the music that he enjoys.
This is not a lot of radio shows like that.
You know what I mean?
So I got to go down there today and do it.
And um,
I knew that guy was funny,
but Jesus quite hung out on his show for like 90 minutes.
And uh,
I,
I could barely keep up with the guy,
you know what I mean?
He's not supposed to be standup comedian level funny,
right?
He's supposed to be musician level.
Funny.
It was fucking unbelievable.
Guy Wasn't noble guy was hilarious.
So if you listen to Iop,
listen to it,
um,
I had a great time on that.
And,
um,
I also realized how little I know about music because he plays all this cool
shit,
you know,
and I listened to all the mainstream stuff,
so he was like,
you know,
think,
what did you listen to a w?
I said I was growing up,
I was like,
you know,
hair metal,
heavy metal,
ac DC,
Stevie ray bond.
It's about it.
And then my dad's big band swing,
I don't think he played he,
that shit on here,
dude.
And he's out playing.
So he ended up playing a motley crew,
uh,
looks at kill and then into ACDC live wire,
which I thought was pretty cool that he did that.
But I was actually kind of nervous that he was going to lose some of his fan
base,
like who is this stupid comedian request in the shit?
Um,
but I don't think we got any goddamn complaints.
you know,
it was cool was he actually had the,
uh,
always at the,
Chelsea arsenal game on in the background.
And,
um,
I just can not get into that
shit unless I'm over it.
If you're over in England,
it's impossible not to get into it.
Everybody gives a fuck.
Everybody's drinking.
People care.
He tried to get into it over here.
It's so fucking quiet.
You know,
which you want a couple of nerdy friends.
It's just no fucking place to watch it at that level to get into it.
But at least what you watched the premier league game,
you can hear the crowd,
how much server intuit.
Um,
but like American soccer,
Jesus Christ,
you can ever fucking pin drop.
Um,
unless Mexico's playing and it's out here in la,
then it sounds like this is amazing.
So he had that game on the background and just watching how much he gave a fuck
plus with his accent,
it was the shit.
And I got into the game and his team went up a two to one and he was nervous
with 10 minutes left.
And the last thing I said to him was like,
dude,
10 minutes left in a soccer game is like 0.8 seconds left in a fucking hockey
game.
And the pucks on the other end of the Isis,
this game is over.
There's nobody.
It was almost like a rule.
They're not going to score four goals at one soccer game.
So I go home and I'm fucking trying to find the Celtics game tonight.
And I,
I went on Fox sports,
they were talking about the game.
It fucking arsenal came back and scored a goal some out in the last 10 minutes.
So it was to,
to,
to ended up in a tie.
I think I jinxed it.
So my apologies.
Um,
but you know what?
I've always been trying to have a fucking team when I was over and I knew there
was no way I could root for man United because that's like when I go over to
England,
I see somebody with a fucking Yankee hat on.
It's like,
ah,
you fucking mouth breathing can't,
why are you a Yankee fan?
Why?
Who could do one new mode?
It's the only fucking team I know the fuck Outta here.
I want to go over there and see somebody with a blue Jay hat on is some shit
like that.
So like there's no fucking way I can,
I can do that.
So,
uh,
I've been trying to pick a team over there and maybe I'll,
maybe I'll follow Chelsea.
I have no idea.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
All I know is it's late at night and I'm,
Oh my God,
I wish I saw that text earlier.
Somebody just fucking texted me.
You going out tonight cigar.
Oh,
that would be tremendous.
Um,
I'm trying to cut down on those fucking thanks to just,
maybe it's good that I didn't see it.
I'm actually going to,
I'm going to try and live the rest of this month the way I lived when I was
eight.
All right.
Which is basically no booze,
no fucking porno,
no cigars.
You know,
I'll go buy a bicycle pretending I have a paper route again.
Um,
I dunno,
I'm fucking enjoying the,
uh,
the clean living and then every once in a while fucking a little debauchery.
Maybe I'll do that.
I'll be fine.
I'll go off for six weeks on for four days.
That wouldn't be bad.
Right?
Would that be bad for your liver?
Um,
the thing is I have too much expensive boots here and I can't just leave it
there and I'm not giving it away.
At some point,
I got to fucking drink it right
by pill.
You know what?
We don't give a fuck about you and your stupid boots.
All right,
I get it.
I'm done talking about it.
Um,
all right,
that's the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
I hope you're having a great,
what are your New Year's resolutions?
What are you doing?
You know what I'm trying again,
that I've failed with all the fucking time is I'm trying to get back to become
fluent in French again.
I'm back on that dual lingo,
fucking trying and out again.
I got the flashcards.
I got all of that shit.
I need a French friend.
You know,
someone who just fucking hang out and talk to me.
Look,
I'm a baby in French.
You know,
the way my kids can learn English,
they think got to teach it that way,
you know,
and you know what it is.
There's been enough people going,
dude,
you never going to learn that shit.
Um,
that's the only way I learned shit is it someone's?
Yeah,
you're never going to do that.
Then I'm like,
I had,
fuck you,
I'm going to do it.
But if they say,
oh yeah,
he should have no problem,
then I blow it off and all right,
fuck it up.
One of the other,
I don't know.
It feels like a fucking therapy session.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
I get nothing.
I got nothing for you.
I got no gigs is fucking month.
I might be doing something.
I might be doing a show in San Francisco cause I'm going up there.
Kevin Pollock for sketch fest.
I'm going up there and I don't,
I don't know,
doing something with him at one in the afternoon at the Castro theater,
which I believe is on the 15th,
the 15th in fucking January.
Hold on a second.
Let me see if this is right.
Let me see.
Let me see the 13th.
It's on the 13th.
Um,
and I might,
I might be doing a couple shows at cops that night.
I'm trying to see if that's going to happen.
I probably shouldn't have said that because it just falls through.
Then they're gonna be like,
what the fuck?
She's doing a born pocketbook.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
Enjoy the music and the new bull play another half hour,
greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon podcasts from a Thursday.
I Dunno,
early this year from years ago.
I have no fucking idea and maybe I'll lose another fence because they say
something about Jesus.
All right.
See Ya.
[inaudible]
what about my week?
I had a fucking insane week and
I went to the rose bowl with a fellow comedian and uh,
I'm not gonna name his name.
Usually I'll do that.
Maybe to give somebody,
you know,
bump up their friends or that type of stuff,
which I'd love to do for this guy,
but not behavior was so,
uh,
colorful.
That's the word I'll use that you know,
just in case,
you know what I mean?
I'm old school.
I don't name names.
When I started talking about a semi crimes that I committed,
not really committing,
well I guess being drunk in public is a crime bill.
Why don't you shut the fuck up and get to the story and we'll,
I'll be the judge.
Fine.
Okay.
You guys with all the tension beginning of 2009 you know,
so you guys be more relaxed this year.
You know,
things going to be fat and 2009 maybe,
although they gotta rhyme,
you know,
just make it rhyme and then,
then,
then I'm supposed to feel good.
You know,
and I'm not supposed to notice that last year it was,
things are going to be great in 2008 and now you've,
you've knocked it down,
announce things,
it'll be fine things.
It'd be great man.
I think to be fine.
You know,
don't freak out in 2010 Ooh.
Did they combine this with Canada in 2011
why am I fucking checking myself out at a grocery store and I'm not getting paid
for it?
Okay,
so my name is,
I go to the rose bowl with a comedian.
We're just going to call him Joe.
All right.
Cause that's the classic alias name.
When you don't want to get somebody in trouble,
you just call him Joe.
But the ironic thing is this guy's name is actually gel.
So me and Joe,
we go to the a fellow comedian and now you can try and figure out who the fuck
he is and it's not fiscal.
Paul.
Um,
we go to the Rose Bowl and,
uh,
we had great intentions.
Okay.
And let me paint a picture for you.
When you go to the rose bowl,
it's one of the great tailgating experiences you'll ever have.
First of all,
you go to the Rose Bowl.
Okay?
The granddaddy of them all home have a bunch of Superbowls Superbowls with fully
that,
that Super Bowl,
uh,
if you see that famous Lynn Swann catch that wasn't made there actually realized
that was made at Temple University,
wasn't it?
I don't fucking know.
There's been a oh nine,
although the Jackie Slater one where he dropped the ball,
that's right.
That that cowboy Steelers won the greatest fucking,
I dunno,
clash of two powerhouse teams I ever saw was the,
uh,
I dunno,
whatever.
They played a bunch of fucking things there.
And I don't have the information in front of me and I'm really killing the
momentum of the story.
So anyways,
he go there,
right.
And uh,
you get right behind the Rosebowl is what I'm assuming is an 18 hole golf
course.
Cause God knows that's how big it felt at the end of the game when I was two
shit faced and we couldn't find the car and we walked for four.
But that,
that I'm getting ahead of myself.
You know what I'm foreshadowing,
I'm doing what all great movies.
Do you know what I mean?
You go see a movie whenever they show a movie about a guy who dies,
everybody he's going to die.
So they show them,
died in the beginning and then the next thing is they go back to his childhood.
You know what I mean?
Except they never do that with the Elvis movie.
Cause then I'd have to start the movie with some fat fuck dying on a toilet and
no one wants to do that.
I'll do as well.
Is that my pancreas?
PLOP.
Um,
anyways,
so Jesus Christ,
let's get some momentum here.
So we fucking,
we go to this tailgate.
All right,
and this is the deal.
Basically,
there's just two of us and amongst us,
we have four hamburger patties,
two bags of chips,
hamburger buns,
12 pack of Bud Light,
12 pack of Budweiser,
and a Clint Eastwood canteens,
size of fucking crown royal,
and to Cuban cigars that I snuck back from fucking Canada.
So we're ready to go.
I got my sunblock,
we loaded up into the Prius,
which is,
uh,
which was just fucking hilarious.
You know,
everybody,
everybody tries to outman people at the,
uh,
at the tailgates,
people coming up there with,
they have their fucking,
you know,
for two or pickups with the lift kits,
the generators.
It's of fucking satellite dish in a flat screen TV.
You know,
I came there with a little Hibachi,
but whatever.
We had the big thing of crown royal,
so people and Cuban cigars.
So no one fucked with us,
right?
So we're having a great time.
All of a sudden this lady comes walking by and she's like,
Hey,
do you want to buy a little ticket holder for your ticket?
I'm like,
absolutely sweetheart,
10 bucks a whack.
Let me get,
let me get that.
Two Times they had baby,
you know,
you've got a cigar in your mouth,
you start getting a little swagger.
Some reason when he likes starts rocking back and forth,
like you've got to sing it.
Like you got to singing Elvis song.
I was failing it.
And the great thing was I didn't give a fuck about either team USC,
all Penn State.
I was just happy to fucking be there,
you know?
But I quickly realized most people were for the Trojans.
So automatically I'm a con second come to the year.
I'm like,
you know what,
I'm going to root for the,
I'm a roof of Penn state because this gives me way more chance to annoy people.
Plus I,
I've never liked USC and uh,
most of it has to do with back in the day,
I used to be a Notre Dame fan before Lou Holtz.
What?
They're holier,
holier than thou.
We don't do steroids.
Shut the fuck up.
Yes you do.
All right.
I had acne when I was fucking a teenager.
Right?
But it wasn't all over my back.
And I also couldn't pick up a house.
Okay,
so you fucking,
people are doing steroids anyways.
And also,
I always hated the Trojans fight song.
They play it every three seconds bad that an ad that,
you know,
they came like half a yard.
And it also reminds me of Fleetwood Mac who I never liked.
So fuck the Trojans,
right?
So anyway,
so we're sitting there,
we're drinking,
we're partying,
would eat burgers and a,
then we break out the crown royal after we had polished off a good half a case
between two of us,
it's probably nine 30 in the morning.
And we just started pounding this crown royal,
which is going down like fucking Koolaid.
I was really impressed with my ability,
or at least the,
the makers of crown royal,
that is some smooth shit.
So,
uh,
so basically we start walking towards the stadium and the alcohol's flowing
through me and that's when I go into my transformation.
I don't know what happens to me at sporting events,
but instantly I just become the loud guy.
I feel like I'm,
I'm doing a comedy show.
I want to make the people around me laugh and I also want to irritate as many
fucking people as I can.
So I start walking in there and I quickly notice,
um,
well I know I went to go buy a program,
I'm trying to put this all back together cause I was pretty drunk.
I go,
just to give you an idea of,
of the mood that I was in,
I get to about a hundred yards from the stadium.
This lady's selling programs and she's like,
yeah,
I get you probe the ad pack.
America gets a bar graphs and like I fuck it.
I want to,
I want a souvenir.
So I walk up and Mike,
how much are they?
She's like,
10 bucks,
my guy.
Fine.
So this other guy comes walking up to cause so much for the programs and the
Lady's like 10 bucks,
right?
And the guy starts bitching to be right.
So I'm standing there,
I got a Cuban cigar.
I go,
you know what,
let me get another one,
two times.
Let me get two of those.
All right,
one for you over there.
And the guy's like,
really?
I go,
Hey,
I go take a look at me.
They know,
you know you're looking at,
you're looking at a big shot.
Take a good look.
There's not a,
there's not a lot of us left.
I swear to God,
I said that and I was so drunk.
I was only half joking.
Like I knew I was being an asshole,
but like I was only half Gif.
Fucking Cuban gone.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'm a big shot.
Let's get a program for this fag over here.
Who's bitching about 10 pool goes to the Rose Bowl and bitches about a $10
fucking program.
You know what I mean?
He should have been de pants and he should have his tickets removed right there
and send right back to wherever the fuck you keep key came from.
Sent to an apple.
Watch the game there.
All right.
Kind of fucking behaviors.
That is the granddaddy of them all.
Thank you.
Fucking money out and play the Goddamn game.
All right.
So when he went and saw him Hammock,
right?
And we're fucking,
we're walking and uh,
I don't know what happened when we got into the stadium.
Everything was cool.
And then they have this weird sort of like they funnel you in,
cause it's a really old stadium.
It's like,
you know it's like trying to go through the Lincoln tunnel like five o'clock at
night.
It's a pain in the ass.
So I'm standing there,
I'm getting frustrated because it's getting close to kickoff and I hate missing
kickoff.
So I'm getting pissed.
And I noticed that the Penn state fans,
they've got this chant where one of them,
I don't know where it just yells,
we are.
And then all the Penn state fans go,
patch stayed.
And then the dude yells again we are and they'll go Penn state and they say it
like five times and then the end,
the guy who starts the chant goes thank you.
And then everybody screams yo welcome.
And I immediately noticed that it annoyed the shit out of all these USC fence.
You know,
cause they kind of felt like it was a home game cause they were out there.
So next thing you know,
I didn't even think it.
Next thing you know,
coming out of my mouth,
I'm going,
we are.
I'm not here,
I'm not from Penn state.
I don't know Shit,
right?
But I just start going,
we got everything starts going Penn state,
Penn state,
and I'm like,
thank you.
And they're like,
Yo,
welcome.
I'm like,
this is fucking awesome.
I can do this the whole game and annoy the shit out of people around me.
So like it took us 20 minutes,
20 minutes to get through the tunnel and I sweated.
I was like,
perfect timing light.
As we got through the tunnel,
this check is finishing singing the national anthem as we just take in the
Roseville on a sunny California day,
everybody's wearing their Trojan colors.
Everybody's wearing that Penn state.
There's pompoms.
People are going fucking nuts.
And this lady's like,
Eh,
no home of the brave.
And what is,
she finished a fucking stealth bomber.
Flies right over the God damn top.
I'm shit face.
It's like a fucking acid trip.
I almost passed out.
Right?
So now,
you know,
we've got end zone seats,
evidently I'm not a big shot and we'll wait at the top of the stadium,
which is a really rough thing to negotiate when you're a redhead drinking
whiskey in the sun,
right?
We get all the way up to like row whatever fucking triple f and you know it's an
old stadium.
Okay.
And you know,
back in the day,
like you were tall if you will,
like five foot six when the stadium was built.
And now you know,
with fucking growth hormones and all the preservatives in the food,
we basically outgrown the stadium's,
not to mention the cheesecake factories that have these fucking people go to
every other day.
So I'm trying to walk a tight rope down.
I'm really acting this out of my bedroom by the way.
This is how into these stories I get to tell.
So I'm literally walking a fucking tight rope trying to get down to my seat and
I just become that guy.
I felt I didn't fall.
I sorta like like list.
It was like almost like I was on his show.
I was the only guy in a ship that was in a fucking with perfect storm and all of
a sudden the whole thing just lifted to the right side and I landed on this like
55 year old ladies back.
Didn't like land like I was doing.
I was on one foot and I put a nice forearm,
oh I'll Samuelson in front of the net fucking action right on her back and I was
so drunk it took me,
I swear to God that at least 28 seconds to get off or in the entire time I am
apologizing with my fucking cigar whiskey breaths,
this gun on site
and I just,
I couldn't get off it cause I the only way to get off or was to put all my
weight on my forearm and use her as a Bannister to push me back up because
nobody's fucking helping me because I'm obviously the drunk guy.
You don't want to touch me.
So 28 seconds to trying to figure out if I have the quad strength to pull myself
up without pushing off the back of this old lady's neck.
I finally just say fuck it and just drive my,
the Meta,
my forearm right between her shoulder blades and I get up and I apologize
profusely and I don't know what Joe was doing at this point.
He was fucking probably just standing there watching the game.
But basically we finally get to our seats.
It was unreal.
I didn't know what,
we got to our seats and I,
we turn around,
we faced the game to watch the game and next thing you know this lady is just
screaming at us.
She's like screaming and she's yelling,
you can't smoke in here.
And I'm like,
what the fuck is she talking about?
Because I put my my cigar out.
I'm going to tell you do the fucking Cuban is sweet too,
man.
I smoked that thing all the way down like a Goddamn Roach.
It's like burning my fucking fingers and she's yelling,
stop smoking.
I'm like the fuck she talking about do I smell like a cigar?
And I tell him,
I looked,
I looked to my right and Joe is standing there with the fucking Cuban cigars.
Gus still lit in his mouth.
I don't know how the fuck he got a past security.
I think it's,
cause we had our tickets,
those tickets,
things I bought around our neck.
I don't know if he had it down by his side,
but he's sitting at chomp on it like fucking Archie bunker.
So
you know,
in the sense of me,
if she just turned around and she had just said,
hey guys,
um,
you know that,
you know,
I don't know if you know,
but there's no smoking in here.
Yeah,
I would have been,
you know,
I'm a happy trunk.
I swear to God.
I'm angry when I'm sober,
but I it,
I'm a happy drunk.
I just would've been like,
hey,
aside bought that,
we didn't know.
Oh,
what do you feel?
Let's see.
All right,
good luck.
Bye.
Ha Ha,
whatever.
I would've kept it at that,
but she fucking was yelling at us.
So I don't like being yelled at.
And I like being,
I like fucking with people and I'm shit faced and Joe is of the same ilk and
then that's when it all started.
She just based,
she's like,
Hey,
she goes,
there's no smoking in here.
And then immediately I just go and I just go.
I'm just like,
Hey,
said.
So she goes to California and I just smoke indoors.
We're like,
we're outside.
And she goes,
you're not allowed to smoke it.
And I go,
you're not my mother.
This isn't our section.
This is in your section turnaround.
Right.
I just kept being an asshole.
And then finally she goes,
I'm going to call security.
And I'm like,
call them.
She goes,
I'm going to call him.
I go,
go ahead and call them.
And then in my head,
my brain is going,
Bill,
shut up,
shut up.
You're going to get,
we're 90 seconds into the game,
you're going to get kicked out.
And I just couldn't stop myself.
I just kept saying column,
column and then,
then she made some sort of comment,
I think about the size of Joe's knows,
and then he said,
hey,
he goes,
you need to lose a hundred pounds to talk to me,
bitch.
He said,
the guy to the left of us turns around and he's like,
Hey,
I got my kid,
I got my kid here.
What do you curse again?
And then Joe goes,
well then don't bring them to a fucking football.
So now I'm doing that laugh.
You know that laugh where like your mouth is wide open but there's no air coming
in or out.
I'm having a time of my life and then the fucking guy goes,
he goes,
I'm going to call security.
And then I'm just,
then at once again,
I'm going,
I'm going to call it God and Call Up Collin.
I was just calling that bluff because we were so fucking jam packed and I knew
they weren't going to walk down there and go do that.
So that lady makes another fucking comment.
At which point Joe makes another comment about her weight and then she just
turns down and it's like mark and yells down to a husband and next thing you
know this fucking dude comes running over and he starts screaming at us and he's
screaming at us.
This spray is coming out of his mouth all over his wife.
So it was easy.
I was just going,
sir,
you're spitting on your wife.
And once you know,
that whole thing was pathetic.
He was like 53 but like,
and I'm 40 and I'm thinking like that.
I'm not too old to fight this guy.
You know,
it was just,
Oh God,
I'm trying to pieces together.
And then so when we all sit down,
right?
So then we sit down.
I think Joe had put out the cigar.
Maybe he's was just holding it down.
I don't know what was coming,
but now by this time we'd already missed the kickoff.
The Trojan's get the ball and I think this is the basically the one good play
Penn state made all day.
They Trojans their first plan.
Thanks offense.
They handed off the ball and they tried to do like some sort of sweep the Penn
state defense strung out and just stuck.
This guy he did for no gain or like lots of one yard.
And then Joe,
cool.
I forgot to mention is a good six foot four.
Just a huge guy.
Just starts screaming like an inch from the back of the Lady's head who's a
Trojan Fan.
He just starts screaming like,
Nah,
I can't believe like her hair wasn't moving.
He was yelling so loud and then she,
I know she turned around and shit.
How that shit,
Nah,
Shit.
That shit.
It was,
it was quite,
it was fucking great.
And then basically what would have for the rest of the game,
shit would calm down and then we would,
we would,
I don't know,
we would mumble something about her and then she would fucking yell down to a
husband and then he'd come over threatening to kick our ass and we would just
laugh at them.
And then,
I dunno,
I just realized I was so drunk,
I can't even remember the rest of,
I remember it was the very end of the game,
uh,
somebody,
Joe,
somebody said something about the score and then the lady in front of us goes,
yeah,
I'm surprised you can count that high.
I go,
yeah,
why don't you try counting calories,
right?
Something real mean like that.
And then once again,
she's like Mk.
And then at this point,
half the crowd in left because it was such a blow out.
This too comes over and he starts fucking screaming at me.
It doesn't scream at Joe because Joe is six foot four.
He yells at me cause I'm fucking barely five 10 and I'm a fucking redhead.
Right.
Even with the shaved head,
I still look like fucking howdy doody.
So he starts yelling at me and he keeps telling me,
yeah I'm going to fire you down on the field.
That's why he kept saying tell me he's going to grab me and fire me down on the
fucking field.
And I was just,
you know,
and I was just being an asshole.
Good,
good.
Do it.
I'm going to fight and built.
You said that,
you already said that.
You already said you already said it.
You fucking cunt.
Right.
If you've got to do it,
you would have and you didn't see you not to sit down and shut the fuck up.
Which is funny because by the end of the game,
everyone in the stands somehow liked us and hated those people.
I mean path of it was cause they were assholes.
The other half was,
they couldn't hear the shit that we will mumble him at.
This dude's wife,
I know at this point he might have a little bit of sympathy for it,
but I mean I'm telling you she was,
she was,
uh,
she was an asshole and she's the one who made it personal first.
She made the comment about Joe's knows she,
uh,
she was doing real hacky lines too.
She's told me I was ugly.
She goes and I always can lose weight,
you know,
which,
uh,
I believe I saw during the second season of def jam and um,
you know,
and I thought,
well we will come in with was a lot more clever and if it was a battle of the
bands in a standup situation,
I think we want.
So,
uh,
basically what ended up happening,
I know this is a long ass fucking story.
I don't even have time for questions this week,
but long story short,
we ended up walking out.
Um,
I want,
I believe that somehow the lady in front of us to who was being a jerk had a
bunch of these ducks streaks on the back of a shirt towards the end of it.
I don't know what it was and almost look like a ashes from a cigar.
But um,
I know that that didn't happen because there's no smoking in there.
But anyways,
we go to leave and we're basically so drunk.
I don't know man.
It took us like fucking nine hours,
literally took us 15 minutes to find our car and I think it was calmer for being
such assholes in,
in,
in the stadium.
And I don't,
I don't know who the fuck set up the parking lot,
the things out there,
but they basically,
the way they do the sections on this golf course is they have like balloons that
they just have numbers,
number one,
number two,
number three.
But they're not lit up.
So you can't really seem at night.
So you walk out of the stadium drunk and you look up and you see,
I saw the number to where we were,
where we were parked and,
but you know,
you've got to follow the path because you can't walk through the sand traps and
shit like that.
So you look down for half a second,
then you look up and there's like a big fucking oak tree in front of you and now
you don't know where you are.
It's like the end of the shining without the shrubs.
It's a fucking golf course,
right?
So,
and you far enough away from the stadium where you can't get your bearings and
were just wandering around and around and around.
And it's getting to the point like,
you know,
like hypothermia is becoming an issue because it's a desert.
It starts getting cold,
was shit faced and we just can't find a car.
It was like the Blair witch.
We kept coming back to the same God damn ladies' teas,
wherever the fuck we were.
And then I lost all confidence in my ability to find the damn car.
So I started following Joe who was convinced,
even though we both know we're,
we're parked in section two,
we went from section three,
section four to section five,
and he keeps telling me to go in that direction because for some reason he
thinks numerically it's going to go three,
four,
five to,
I dunno,
it took us an hour to find the fucking car.
And uh,
at that point I started sobering up and I started thinking about our behavior
and I was starting to thinking like,
you know,
I kinda Kinda filling an asshole.
Yeah.
You know,
I shouldn't say I shouldn't taken the higher ground even though they throw was a
content,
you know.
And he was just like,
what are you talking about?
What are you talking about?
She was a cunt.
We treated it like one and that's it.
It's quite a lot about that guy.
He just,
he just breaks it down to the simplest fucking point.
Hey Buddy,
I've got my kid hit.
Well,
don't take your kid to a fucking football game.
Which,
you know,
I know that's harsh,
especially if you have kids.
But think about it.
Think about it.
Why would you bring your kid to was professional to sporting event.
Not only that,
that the guy with the kid is being hypocritical because he was me before he had
a kid.
All right?
He was having the time of his fucking life and what now?
Because he has a kid now all of a sudden I'm supposed to,
I'm supposed to fucking act my age.
You know,
it's like the fucking baby boom generation.
They Bang so much the fucking in the mud at Woodstock that by the time I come
around there's herpes and aids and all this shit and then these,
you know,
and then they come around with their don't do drugs where a condom shit after
they had the time of their fucking lives.
I'm so glad all of them are getting that whole generation is getting hip
replacements now with their fucking cause.
They all had that fucking Olivia Newton,
John High impact aerobics tape that they did try to stay in shape.
It's the one good fucking thing.
Consider I got to fuck with a God damn trash bag around my dick my entire
career.
Right.
The very least,
I at least knew to stretch before you lifted weights.
And I also dangers of high impact aerobics.
Okay.
When I did my aerobics,
I definitely was rocking the leg warmers,
but I did not let my feet leave the ground.
Okay.
So anyways,
so that's my rose bowl story.
Um,
it's a fucking law when I know that,
but I think it had some nice moments.
But um,
yeah.
But getting back to that,
what do you guys think about that stuff?
You know,
sporting events are not for children.
Okay.
And I know they always try to talk about the good old days of sports.
The goal days of sports is bullshit.
Okay.
When I was a kid,
first football game I went to,
I was fucking terrified.
I was terrified.
It was not a place for kids.
It was a place for adults who hadn't achieved what they thought they were gonna
achieve in life to get their fucking anger and frustration out.
People with in loveless marriages,
you know,
people,
people who could tell they were going to get laid off the next week or maybe the
audio got laid off and they just wanted to get it out.
Okay.
And they,
you know,
they've now turned going to a fucking football game into like,
you're standing in line with a bunch of people waiting to get their kids,
you know,
photo taken with Santa Claus.
You know,
and even if you go further back than my childhood,
which was seventies,
early eighties,
um,
do you go back to the 1950s they talk about that?
Oh,
the good old days of sports or what do you mean what,
what,
when,
uh,
when they finally let a black guy playing baseball and they said,
we'll fucking black cat on the field and all that racist shit that was going on.
Can you imagine the shit that was getting yelled in the stands when Billy
crystal was going down to la to go ahead and go watch the mic.
Oil Boy had got myself a hot dog and assessed Barilla.
You know,
they always tell us stories about how great it was back then.
It wasn't,
it wasn't great.
They were way more racist,
way more ignorant,
way more sexist.
And people went to the games and they saw Johnny Unitas.
Okay,
so now for some reason,
now it's my turn to be an asshole and it'd be a drunk and have a good time and
all of a sudden I have to take everything down a level,
you know,
not now.
Now it's,
it's Chuckie cheese time.
It isn't.
And I know you guys are saying,
well that's because you don't have a kid right now.
No,
fuck that.
Fuck that.
I wouldn't bring my kid to the game.
Or if I brought to give to the game,
I would prepare him.
I prepare them,
you know,
this is what's going to happen.
Okay.
You might see a fight,
you know,
hey,
dad might even get in one.
No,
I never took it to that level.
But you know what I mean?
I think,
uh,
I dunno,
again,
this is how guilty I am for my behavior that they,
I actually pulled up a quote from George Orwell who,
uh,
granted this is from Wikipedia,
which the other day I looked up something that I knew something about and was
completely inaccurate.
But this is according to Wikipedia,
George Orwell said,
serious sport has nothing to do with fair play.
It's a bound up.
It's bound up with hatred,
jealousy,
boastfulness disregard of all rules and sadistic pleasures,
pleasures and witnessing violence.
In other words,
it's war minus the shooting.
Exactly.
Now,
why the fuck would you bring a child to that?
And not only that,
when was George Orwell alive
a long fucking time ago?
I don't know when he was alive.
When did he write?
1984 he didn't write it in 83.
I know that he wrote like the 30.
Stephanie.
I'm just saying.
See,
that's how he described sports back then.
So guys,
like,
you know,
these Billy crystal guys always do those little heartwarming stories about,
uh,
you know,
their baseball cards and going down to the baseball stadium and acting like it
was this fucking,
you know,
this time that was lost,
George Orwell's right there according to Wikipedia,
the guy proved my point.
I'm a moron,
but I did have a good time.
I'm going to tell you,
write this right now.
If you ever get a chance in your life to smoke a Cuban cigar,
definitely do it all right.
Because I'm not even a big smoker.
And I could tell how fucking amazing that cigar was because I've drank fine
wines and I can't tell the difference,
you know?
And it took me a long time to be comfortable with myself.
You know,
when he goes through the whole long process of spinning the big red wine glass
around,
I see red up on wine to try to learn.
So I,
you know about it.
So I wouldn't feel so fucking stupid when they bring a nice bottle of wine over
and I'm like,
you know,
this tastes like the shit I used to drink in high school.
You know,
I learned that,
you know,
red wine.
The reason why it's in a bigger glass is because I'm about the oxygen and you
want it to breathe more and how to,
you know,
move it around the fucking table and then you shove your fucking nose all the
way in it and yet put it in your,
switch it all around your mouth.
I got all the moves down and I'm like swallowed up Mike.
Yes.
This tastes like every other fucking red wine I've ever had.
That's not true.
I can tell a difference between like,
you know,
a Cabernet or my low or something like that.
But like I can't tell like the difference between a 1499 bottle and a,
a $60 bottle and uh,
you know,
I guess I'm trying to say with this podcast,
I'm not that culture.
Okay.
All right.
Well,
so why don't you guys shine in what that,
okay.
Like,
well,
do you think David,
they should have a kids section two.
They just have a Chucky cheese section.
It's not my fault.
You're knocked her up and you can't go to a game and have a good time now.
You know you want to be getting drunk with me.
See what I just did there.
That's how I made myself write made this guy who can't even defend himself
actually be secretly agreeing with me.
That's how I do it.
But I mentioned I have a
so
[inaudible],
hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and this is the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
January 4th,
2010 and I'm having a lot of difficulty doing this fucking podcast right now
because I feel like this is like,
you know,
it's my second attempt to start it.
I can already feel like this one's going to fucking suck because I feel like I
can't fucking do what it is that I do cause my downstairs neighbors a fucking
cunt.
You know,
I told you guys that story,
but my downstairs fucking neighbor,
how he waits till I'm on the road and he starts yelling at my girlfriend about
how loud she is,
you know?
And then when I come back,
all of a sudden he doesn't yell.
He's like real sarcastic.
He used to do it,
you know,
if I drop something he'll be like,
do it again.
Right.
This old guy.
So you know,
I'm a deck so I fucking,
whatever I dropped,
I dropped it from a foot higher,
you know,
like how was that yelled?
Fuck you know,
this isn't even,
this isn't even like my attitude towards the guy.
Alright?
My girl,
you know,
she,
she called me and she said,
look,
this guy's yelling at me.
I'm really getting tired of this shit.
You know,
I want you to go downstairs and say something to the guy.
Okay.
And if you guys listen to my podcast,
you know,
I came to the resolution,
like,
what?
Where is that going to get me?
I'm not going to go downstairs and get into it with some old guy.
Okay.
I don't fucking yell at old people.
All right.
I might whisper about them and call him consult on my fucking podcast.
Okay.
But I have a SPEC face to face.
Okay?
He's old.
He doesn't have the Internet.
He's never going to hear this shit,
you know.
So anyways,
long story short is a yesterday and when the fuck was,
it was too,
it was January 2nd you know,
I get a big thing January 2nd Christmas tree comes down.
That's it.
It's fucking over.
All right?
I wait until the end of new years.
I went to all that stuff.
Happy New Year.
I'll that Abby,
if I got ag,
go fuck yourself.
I go through all of that shit.
But the second that's over,
it's like,
all right,
it's,
you know,
it's game time.
Alright,
back to reality.
It's no fat fuck coming down the goddamn chimney.
I didn't have a fucking chimney.
I have a boarded up fireplace.
All right?
So Christmas is on me.
If I don't go to best buy,
it ain't happening.
You know?
So you know,
that's one of those fucking things.
If you've got kids,
if you've got kids right now,
don't have,
don't have him listen to this part.
That's one of those fucking things.
If you're a parent,
right?
And you know,
and you're renting a place like mine that has a fucking boarded up fireplace,
that's when you know the questions come,
you know,
and you get even further into the lie,
you know?
Okay.
Santa Claus,
Jay do average gifts.
Yeah.
Everybody around the world.
Yes he does.
Hey Shay comes down at Chevy.
How's he going to do it?
Well actually in our place,
um,
there is a chimney he comes down at and he has a secret key.
A has a secret key and he's able to unload and you're just sitting there and you
had go on Jesus.
How deep?
You know what?
There is no
fucking Santa Claus.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
How fucking dumb is the person that I made it with that you actually still
believe this shit cause I know that that's not my half of the brain asking that
fucking question.
Alright kid,
do the fucking math.
You know,
fat fuck has time to deliver all these gifts to everyone around the world.
And even though you can't even grasp the reality of that,
we have boarded up fucking fireplace.
Alright,
come on.
Let's he get him back his fat ass to the fucking thing.
So anyways,
so it's January 2nd.
Okay.
Fucking trees coming down and uh,
I don't do it most Douche bags too.
Okay.
I don't fucking just,
you know,
drive down the highway and toss it off on the fucking medium strip,
like some sort of mob snitch.
All right.
I don't,
I give two in the back of the fucking anyone to actually do.
I take it outside.
All right.
I fucking whack my Christmas tree.
Like fucking a Vigoda.
Remember that in and the Godfather and he looks at Robert Duvall,
you know,
hey,
fulltime sake,
sorry.
Sorry.
Fish can't do it.
That's,
that's how I take,
I take my tree out to the fucking driveway and then I cut it up like a fucking
body.
I do,
I fucking saw off all the limbs and then I,
I cut up the trunk and like four or five different sections.
And I stick it into the green trash bin like I'm supposed to.
All right?
Then I sweep up the pine needles out of the driveway and all the fucking ones
out of my living room.
And that's the end.
There you go.
Another Christmas,
go fuck yourself.
Right?
So this is a deal.
You know,
when you first get to Christmas tree,
you're watering it.
Oh,
Christmas tree.
And three days into it,
you're so fucking stressed out,
you stop watering it.
You start telling yourself what's fucking dead anyways.
You know it's on its last legs,
whatever,
right?
So basically by the time you drag the fucking thing out that the tree is so God
damn dead,
all right,
it's,
you know,
pine needles fall out,
the little needles,
they fall out everywhere.
All right?
And I know they're not pine needles for all you fucking nature freaks out there.
Whatever the fuck they are,
the goddamn evergreen needles,
they start falling all over the place.
So I bring it out my front door,
stand in awe,
and I start dragging it down the fucking stairs.
Okay?
And I'm trying not to be loud,
okay.
But I am taking a tree down a flight of fucking stairs.
All right.
Fucking water spilling.
The needles are going all over the place,
you know,
but I'm being quiet and it's 10 in the fucking morning.
Okay.
If I wanted to build a house that could actually legally start at seven in the
morning,
it's 10 in the fucking morning,
right?
So I dragged the thing around and I'll bring it around the back and all of a
sudden fucking a grumpy old man sticks his head out the door and he looks at me
and he just screams.
But this bizarre look on his face.
He just said something like the fuck did he say he just yelled out,
beautiful morning,
isn't it?
You know?
And I was looking at him like,
why the fuck did he just say something so nice with that angry look on his face?
And for half a second I was going mad,
man,
I think that guy's crazy.
You know,
you might be that guy in clockwork orange food.
All right.
You know?
So I was like,
I just sort of looked at him and I kept going.
I always forget that he's fucking sarcastic as hell.
And whenever he says he means the exact fucking opposite,
he's basically saying,
yeah,
what a beautiful fucking morning if you'd make an all this God damn noise.
So I walked back around again.
This time I look at him,
cause now at this point I finally figured out he was fucking with me.
So I'm,
you know,
I'm staring down an old man,
right?
This,
this is really embarrassing story.
So I walk up,
I walk upstairs,
right?
I stared at him,
he stares at me.
He doesn't say a fucking word cause that's it.
That's as emo.
He doesn't like confrontations.
He says shit.
He doesn't mean he means the exact opposite.
And he yells at people through floors.
All right?
And He fucking lives alone.
If it's really sad situation.
Okay.
So what happens?
So I go upstairs.
All right.
My girls all heated.
He just fucking yelled at me again.
Right.
Are at our hour.
I want you to go down that time.
My God,
right.
I'll fucking do it against my good judgment.
Do not go down there against my gut saying,
what the fuck good is gonna come out of this?
So I go down there and I walked down and he's fucking sitting there right now.
He's got this brick path.
You got to walk up and he's sitting at the end of it just staring at me,
right?
Expected me to walk by his path.
But Lo and behold,
I make a left and I start walking up his path like some sort of fucked up,
high noon Shit.
And I'm staring right at the guy.
Okay.
And you know what I saw on his face?
I saw fear and I see did what all guys do while you fucking cunt.
Jesus Christ,
Carson Palmer,
just through a fuck another interception.
The checks are up 24 nothing.
Oh my God,
it's fucking over.
Have you ever seen a fucking team back into the playoffs?
More than the fucking jets did?
Jesus Christ.
I'll tell you right now,
I fucking hate the cults as a Patriots Fan,
but I'll tell you right now,
you know,
maybe just sidestep this fucking story.
Let me just tell you something right now.
I feel bad for everybody in Indianapolis that should not happen to sports fans.
When you're going for something like that,
you should lose it because you got beat by a better team.
You don't put in fucking some guy from home depot to be quarterback Jesus
Christ.
This is killing my prediction that Rex Ryan was going to make an attempt on his
fucking life.
I think the NFL knows it.
So they pulled Peyton manning out.
I bet everybody in Indianapolis Douche bag in the week is you fucking GM or
whatever the hell made that God damn call.
So now this week they're playing the fucking Goddamn Bengals who had their best
receiver fall off the back of a fucking truck.
I mean,
Jesus Christ,
I hope we don't play them.
I want to do fuck what's going to happen to our team.
I think the jet's got some sort of Mojo going.
If they're on your schedule,
something fucking horrific is going to happen.
You're going to make a bad decision or somebody's going to die.
So anyways,
so I'm walking up to this fucking old guy,
right?
And,
uh,
and I see fear on his face and he does what all guys do when they get scared is
they turn the fear into anger so they can function during this thing.
And my whole thing is,
I'm coming down here,
going,
build,
don't lose your cool.
Let's try to fucking work this shit out with this guy.
Shall I just say,
uh,
Hey,
you know,
I came out the fuck I said,
I just said,
you know,
I,
you're kind of always yelling up at my girlfriend.
We always hear you yelling up at us.
I was just,
you know,
wondering what the problem was.
He's like,
what are your main problem?
Is faces all fucking twisted up.
And I'm like going,
oh Jesus,
here we go.
And I'm like,
no,
you know,
I just,
I know that you think that we're loud.
We try to walk around,
not put our shoes on,
you know,
I just want to come down here and you know,
I just want to work it out.
And he goes,
what do you mean work it out?
I don't like,
you know,
try to come to some sort of resolution or whatever.
And he just starts fucking going.
She just shout or latch.
You just dropped a brick on a damn floor.
He's screaming now he's screaming out.
He's fucking voice is echoing through the courtyard.
Okay.
And I'm fucking sitting there trying to be civil,
but I don't give a fuck.
He just bang on the fucking floor.
I'm doing an impression of you.
You fucking asshole.
So he bangs on the fucking,
I think it just banged on the fucking floor.
Do this fucking,
I'm 41 year old fucking man.
I'm still dealing with somebody downstairs.
This is ridiculous.
I've got to get a fucking house.
Um,
anyways,
so he starts fucking yelling.
I don't give a fuck.
Even if you were in that loose man,
I'm whisper on my own fucking podcast.
Fucking contract guys been here 50 years.
He's probably paying $7 a month in rent.
Um,
so anyways,
okay.
Yeah,
I don't give a shit.
The second an old person is yelling at you,
even if you're being relaxed and when people immediately think that you're an
asshole,
you know,
it's Kinda like when it checks,
what was it drinking your face?
It's awfully,
well,
yeah,
obviously you did something.
She has a vagina,
right?
Obviously I did something,
his fucking whole body body looks like a fucking wrinkled up,
nuts sack,
you know?
So this guy has fucking yelling at me and I'm going,
dude,
I'm,
I'm like,
I didn't say,
dude,
I was trying to be a restaurant list side trying to work things out.
He goes,
what do you mean that work it out?
He's like,
what?
It,
what does that some sort of new hip expression?
I what he said,
it's like,
oh my God,
did he just say some new hip expression?
And he's going,
you know,
you're always walking across with his shoes.
And I'm like,
dude,
you think I can't hear your TV?
It's an old building.
What do you want me to do?
And he goes,
AH,
why don't you get lost,
right?
Like I'm in some little rascals episode,
like fucking three stooges.
Why don't you a Scram,
right.
So I just kept going.
No,
I didn't come down here to argue with you.
I'm,
I'm trying.
He goes,
I already called the landlord about Ya.
And I was like,
well call him again.
Call him again.
You think they're afraid of you moving out with your fucking $3 a month rent
fucking asshole.
They had ever called me cause they don't give a shit cause you're out of your
fucking mind.
So at one point I'm trying to make a point to the guy and he just goes,
how's your band?
Like making fun of the fact that I play guitar and I suck.
He said it unbelievably sarcastic and really hurt my feelings for half a second.
He,
he's so caught me on a nowhere with that that I wanted to,
I almost started reading my resume.
I almost said actually I'm not an event.
Actually I'm a comedian and I'm playing the Improv next week.
Thank you very much.
Like that's how bad this guy caught me and pardon me after he said,
you know,
how's the bad?
How's your band?
I wanted to be like,
dude,
how's she a fucking life?
You know?
But I didn't.
I didn't because I don't yell at old people.
It probably sounds like I do.
By the way,
I'm saying this,
this is the shit afterwards,
when I'm fencing about it,
they can't really fuck me up.
So finally I was just like,
you know what?
You're being a jerk.
Oh,
is that right?
And as you have,
right,
he's actually,
I'm showing a new hip term,
fucking sitting there shaking like a leaf.
So fine.
I just,
I walked away and little did I know that my girlfriend was standing on a balcony
above all of it,
listening to all of it.
So not only did she
instigate the whole fucking thing telling me to go down there,
she actually got to listen to sky trash,
my guitar playing,
which by the way,
we both laughed our asses off about.
But before we did,
I went upstairs.
Okay.
And at this point I'm just sitting there like mad at myself.
Go,
why didn't you listen to yourself,
bill?
You knew that that wasn't going to go anywhere.
Right?
So any fucking way I go upstairs and I see my goal,
I don't care what you say is right.
They go,
is that what the fuck you wanted?
Is that what the fuck wanted?
I told you if that wasn't going to go anywhere,
that wasn't going to go anywhere.
And now what he's going to do is he's going to call all the fucking landlord and
he's going to bitch to high fucking heaven and he's going to exaggerate
everything that fucking went on down there.
Okay.
Unfucking believable.
And the thing was,
I felt really bad the second I got down there.
I just kept trying to go,
no,
I'm trying to work this out and everything.
I would say he would just repeat it and be like,
what is that?
You know?
And I trashed my guitar playing and,
and I,
I,
oh my God,
I was like,
Jesus Christ.
I was like embarrassed.
I was actually embarrassed.
I was like,
wow,
he can fucking hear me.
I know I suck.
I thought I played a quiet enough.
So now my pee was my aunt.
I got headphones on the next day.
And I'm playing my awful ACDC.
It's a fucking hobby,
you know,
that'd be able to get a hobby old fuck.
Like getting some French.
See,
see that's why I,
that's why I kept my cool cause I would've said Shit like that,
you know,
that's fucking bro them.
And you know what's funny is my girl still fucking pissed at the guy.
It's like a female thing I think.
Cause he's a guy and she kind of feels like he's bullying her and stuff and I
just kept telling him going,
you know what?
I feel bad for the guy.
I just slammed the door downstairs.
Am I being fucking loud?
It's just ridiculous.
I'm like borderline whispered here.
So maybe you can hear the fucking story
as his passive aggressive way of saying he disagrees with my last point.
Yeah.
Slam something else.
You can't do they have that word back in the 20s of what does that mean?
It's actually I'm new hip word for vagina.
Um
Yeah so I was just saying I,
you know,
I feel bad for the guy.
I have to whisper this part cause he might hear cause to tech guy isn't the
exact fucking nightmare.
Okay.
There's two ways you don't want to die in prison and you don't want to be that
old person alone.
You don't,
okay.
you know,
if your spouse dies,
that's a different fucking story because you live life,
you know,
but you know it's,
you don't wanna be the person who never got fucking married,
got even have a Goddamn parakeet.
Fucking always has the blinds,
you know?
I know I didn't want,
I didn't want to get in a fight with this fucking guy.
I feel like an asshole.
Yeah,
I really feel like a fucking asshole.
So that's my situation right now and I,
you know,
that's my situation.
Like the guy in the Jersey shore.
Do you guys watch it this week?
I don't even know what week I'm on.
I fucking watched the first half of that shit.
I gotta tell you Mike,
the situation is my new fucking hero.
They actually finally showed the footage because when snuck he got punched in
the face.
I was wondering like where the fuck were all the guys,
how come they didn't do anything and they showed the footage of Mike the
situation.
Mack the situation,
he didn't do it.
Not only did he not do anything,
he continued to hit on the girl that he was with and that's why I thought it was
hilarious if he didn't do anything because he was scared that would have been
something else.
But like this girl gets blasted in the face by this guy.
She's on the floor sobbing and he just looked at it almost like the way a wild
animal looks at you across the fucking cage.
You know when it's just sort of looking at you,
you know,
sees you're not a threat or whatever and he's just immediate looks at the girl.
He switched you.
Yeah,
you want to get somebody,
you know,
you want to get some knee,
I'll show you my age.
It's fucking hilarious.
And then watching all those other guys in the house going,
you know Mikey the situation and he shot a whole fucking day.
What did he do?
He did nothing.
What do you mean he didn't,
he did know God,
the situation.
She was shit new sage was in,
played a Tortellini.
Oh,
it's like the most offensive fucking show on TV.
But that was some,
that was fucking hilarious.
He didn't do a fucking,
he could,
he could give a fuck.
And they all sit there going,
yeah,
it's not a true friend.
You fucking right.
It isn't
whatever.
Mike,
the situation knows what he wants.
He does want to get in the middle of that shit.
Yeah.
I have fucking meatball standing up there screaming at that fucking ugly gym
teacher.
Um,
anyways,
I didn't want to talk about,
now I'm all fucking self conscious because that fucking
guy downstairs,
I was wondering about his life.
Like how did he end up down there?
You know,
you ever see old people like that?
Like how does,
how did that happen?
You know,
Jesus Christ is out here in la,
probably fucking tested for Mchale's navy,
you know,
went to network,
staring across it.
Ernest Borgnine going this motherfucker.
I thought he did movies.
Um,
anyways,
um,
I don't know where to go with this fucking podcast.
I'm really kind of lost right now because,
uh,
because of that,
that shit.
Um,
so I dunno,
I was going to nominate the guy downstairs Douche bag of the week.
I would have done that five minutes ago when I was still pissed at a night.
I just felt bad for the guy.
Feel bad for the guy.
I feel bad about the whole fucking situation.
Jesus Christ.
This guy was like trembling as he was yelling at me.
He was so out of his mind.
I kept trying to calm him down going,
I'm trying to work this out.
Cat lost,
you know,
the whole thing took like fucking it maybe two and a half minutes.
Hm.
Anyway,
so what,
I don't know where the fuck to go from this.
Oh,
by the way,
if you guys seen that fucking scam on TV with that,
that they're trying to sell you that gold coin for 1995,
the $50 gold coin for 1995 and in the end they start talking about how an ounce
of gold is worth like is selling for 1200 bucks.
Okay.
I mean that's one of those things where
I don't feel bad for re I like for people who buy shit like that.
You know what I mean?
If you're too stupid to realize that somebody selling you a $50 coined for 20
bucks,
that that person would be going broke $30 a coin if you're too dumb to do the
fucking math on that.
And then also not to hear how they go.
14 karat gold and then they use this term.
I figured I was gonna write the term down.
I forget what it is,
but it basically means
they basically,
they picked up a rock at the beach and they sort of dusted it with 14 karat gold
and it's so lightly dusted with this fucking gold that they can actually sell it
for 1995 and still probably become multimillionaires and one of the great lines
in it is limit five per customer.
Also to put that in your head like,
Oh fuck,
oh wait a minute.
People at these things going to be gone.
People are buying five of these.
This is a great investment.
This is a great investment thing.
You know,
in case the economy goes south,
I'll have these $50,
1995,
1995 gold coins that they sprayed with the same shit that they spray the cast of
the Jersey shore with people that just did fucking morons.
Go ahead,
go buy five of them and hide them and you snuggies you've dumped fucks.
Oh,
that's what I should buy the guy downstairs.
I'm going to buy him a fucking snuggie as a peace offering.
You know,
get them that in a packaging of fucking earplugs.
Ah,
what does that mean back in my day and we just weren't deaf.
Um,
all right,
you guys want to watch a fucked up youtube video?
I got one for you.
That's actually not even on Youtube.
It's on a new website.
It's called a today's big thing.
T o d a y s,
big thing altogether.
All lowercase.
Look up.
Uh,
this is what you search.
Write it down.
Get a posted.
Okay.
Act like you're on the phone and you're fucking doing something.
It's a no for those of you driving around.
It's 22 minutes,
26 seconds into the podcast.
If you want to fast forward to write this down.
Look up,
may be in fucking user friendly.
Uh,
it's called,
uh,
www dot today's big thing.com.
Um,
back slash 2009 back slash 12 backslash 30,
um,
it's a fat guy jumping into a frozen lake.
And,
uh,
he goes right through the fucking ice and there's a moment there where,
I dunno,
I didn't really find it to be a funny video and I thought his friends who are
unbelievably ignorant,
um,
with their incredible,
uh,
lack of urgency with the situation,
the situation,
I don't know how quick hypothermia sets in,
but,
uh,
I dunno,
judging by his does the fucking way to this guy and that the stress that's
already putting on his heart,
the kid easily could have had a fucking heart attack and they were trying to
pull the mother fucker out and it's unreal.
He ends up walking out of the lake like Godzilla.
He's just going to break the fucking ice all the way back to the show.
Oh fuck,
I'm sorry.
They're fucking image.
Just hit me.
Ah,
all right.
Anyways,
anyways,
as podcast sucks,
I got to bring the energy.
All right.
Uh,
let's talk about me right now I'm on the wagon.
I am seriously on the wagon.
I went to the rose bowl again this year and this year,
rather than bringing a camera,
I bought my flip phone and I was videotaping and I was just embarrassed by my
behavior and it's not funny.
It's just embarrassing and no,
I won't be uploading it and know it will never be extras and a,
if you will,
part of the tailgate next to me.
Remember when I said I was going to email you the,
uh,
some of the footage that I took,
I'm not sending it to you because I'm in it and I am,
I'm just really embarrassingly drunk.
I sounded like animal and every foe you remember animal from the muppet show,
but I love,
that's what I sounded like the entire fucking time.
And,
uh,
you know,
is the worst thing too,
was the next day when I watched the footage,
not only being that drunk,
but when I was actually looking at the unbelievable,
a spectacle that is the rose bowl.
And to realize that I've gone to a two years in a row and can barely remember
more than 30 seconds of it.
I'm watching the jets game right now and I just realized that he was playing
quarterback for USC last year in the Rose Bowl.
I actually sort of saw him play,
but I was too busy yelling at the fat chick in front of me and listening to her
husband's telling me that he was going to throw me down to the field.
So,
uh,
this year I actually passed out for eight minutes of the second quarter just out
like a light,
like an old person in a fucking rocking chair,
two in the afternoon,
just out,
you know,
fucking,
$600 a day after all is said and done the fucking Cuban cigars and all the
bullshit and the parking.
Now I'm just fast asleep,
granddaddy of them all.
It's just a fucking mess.
Maybe the footage will be funny at some point because I got to admit every other
thing is me cutting to my buddy who's drunk or each time and every time he just,
he just looks at the camera and he sort of slurs granddaddy of them all.
It was bad.
I was hammered and I was making he,
we brought like these fucking Ribeye steaks that she's fucking sweet things,
right?
So we forget a knife.
My buddy is buttering them up with his index finger and uh,
I put enough charcoal on there to cook a fucking Bronto Burger.
So the second the flames hit that butter.
Oh my God.
It was unreal.
It was like the outside was well done in the inside was still cold
and everyone was just watching me going,
hey buddy,
don't flip the steak too much.
It's like,
I can't,
I can't not flip it.
It's fucking hot as hell.
And it was bad and uh,
it was really bad.
It was really bad and I'm fucking it,
you know,
I'm just really embarrassed with myself.
I scared an old man.
I was drunk off my ass.
Like I've been to Rosewell twice and I really don't even feel like I've been to
it.
I mean I was in there but I don't remember any of it and I don't know what
happened.
I can't name one fucking player.
You know that Guy Blount who punch that dude on a Boise state?
I don't know the name of one person on Ohio state.
I don't know the name of one person,
an Oregon.
All I know is Oregon hasn't won the rose bowl since 1913.
I did learn that and evidently cheap trick was somewhere there playing and uh,
this is how much I was drinking and how much I was enjoying it.
W We got there at eight 30 in the morning for a one 30 kickoff and within two
seconds it was like Wah.
It was almost one 30 or two o'clock kickoff after all the bullshit.
And uh,
I was actually annoyed.
I was like,
why couldn't have been like a four o'clock game?
I'm having a good time.
And once again,
we had a couple of big bottles of crown royal and we had a whole case of beer
between the two of us.
And for the life of me,
I don't know where it all went.
It was,
it was just gone.
It was fucking gone.
And at the end of the night I bought,
you know,
none of that you want to set.
How about overrated expensive sunglasses.
Okay.
I've gotten a couple as like gifts and I always lose them on planes.
Right?
So this time I finally go out and buy a pair.
All right.
And I don't take them on the road with me.
And this time I actually brought him,
you know,
made a little checklist this year for the Rose Bowl and I fucking brought him
the end of the game.
I got um,
you know,
tucked into my fucking tee shirt and my buddy comes up.
Uh,
when a game,
it gives me a big hug and I just hear
they didn't break.
They just could fit on a,
I dunno,
pick somebody with a huge fucking head.
They could fit on that person's head now.
So it was bad.
So I actually came home and I dumped out all the beer that I had in the fridge.
I had dumped out the rest of my head a little,
uh,
fucking,
you know,
those little fucking flask things ahead of that Jim beam.
I dumped that out.
I had a little bit more left quarter of a bottle of gentleman jack.
I know people cringe and I dumped out.
And then I got this 15 year old scotch.
I kept that,
but I'm shutting it down,
shutting it down.
I'm not going to fucking Aa,
but I'm shutting it down.
And next year I'm not drinking at the Rose Bowl.
I'm just not.
Okay.
I'm getting up fucking respectable grill and I'm going to redeem myself.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
It's just for his fucking pathetic.
My behavior was just completely,
and I just looked like such a douche bag.
I don't know.
Gee,
Bill,
what a week.
Huh?
You got to,
did you do anything good this week?
Alright,
let's see.
What did I do that,
you know what I oh,
Jesus Christ.
Can you fucking tackle somebody is 27 nothing.
The jets.
You know what the jets are the jets like red sox fans where they don't
understand.
I cannot red sox fans don't seem to understand that.
Singing sweet Caroline is one of the gayest things ever.
I got to admit,
you know something.
I respect jets fan because you're a hardcore fan.
If you follow that fucking team because they kick you in the seeds every year,
right before they twist your heart out of your chest.
So I totally fucking respect.
Even though I can't stand you because you were in a fucking division.
But I'm telling you do when they put that fireman,
when that guy lifts the other guy up on his shoulders and he's dressed like he's
in the fucking village,
people with that stupid fireman hat and don't even fucking email me and tell me
who you are.
Actually a real fireman.
I don't give a fuck.
All right.
If you're wearing a fireman helmet and you're not on your way to a fire or
sitting in a fucking firehouse,
okay,
you look like an asshole.
All right?
And when he,
j e t s jets,
jets,
you know something.
That's the only thing of this year that my downstairs neighbor would understand
because that is a fucking,
that's like,
it's like a fucking cheer from the 1920s e t is judge,
judge,
and they're all pumping their fist.
Like those guys on the Jersey shore listening to house music.
It's really,
really fucking bad.
And uh,
speaking of which,
why do you guys need a new stadium?
What's wrong with that?
That stadium is fine.
You know what it is?
It's a,
this is some sort of scam going on with those new stage because the amount of
fucking new stadiums that they built,
I kind of understood the new Yankee stadium,
you know,
it's not like they didn't have the money to fucking
yeah,
fix it up again.
I guess they already did it,
but the Meadowlands is only like what,
30 35 years old
and they build another one right next to it.
It looks like the exact same fucking thing.
Oh,
let me guess what.
He can get Sushi at this one.
So now it's $200 more for a seat.
We got even bigger seats because everybody's even fatter now.
Um,
anyways,
all right.
Last week I did a segment called oh Jesus,
where,
uh,
you know,
I stated my opinions on what I felt about organized religion and all that type
of stuff and I got a shitstorm of emails.
But believe it or not,
most of them were very complimentary.
I'm saying that's exactly how I agree.
I how I feel.
Um,
you know,
hell,
I cares.
Once somebody said,
dear bill,
southern mega church is a corporate monster that needs to die to trick of the
church is that they've been perfecting their scam since man started blaming
natural phenomenon on God's,
it's all based on fear.
And the constant charge decided at some point point that they could make money
off of it.
I don't blame the sheep for believing the shepherd.
Blame the wolf for dressing like a shepherd.
Uh,
you know what?
I agree with that.
I think that's a great point.
But you know,
I have to admit past a certain age,
you're a moron if you believe stuff like that.
You know what I mean?
It's like if you're in your 20s you can still blame your parents for shit that
they did to you.
You know?
And maybe that's why you're a little dysfunctional,
but you kind of work that shit out and that becomes a point in your life where
you got to stop blaming your fucking parents.
You got to take charge of your own life and when you fuck up,
you got to take it on yourself.
All right?
Jesus Christ,
the fucking jets are running a Goddamn wishbone offense.
Okay.
Do you know what the genius of that is?
Like the reason why they never did it in the prose is because the quarterback
gets fucking stuck,
you know?
And he can't have Joe Montana getting stuck trying to gain fucking six yards on
the ground.
Right?
But now the geniuses is they,
they,
they stay stick like a fucking wide receiver or running back in there.
Why didn't anyone who came,
does anybody into football enough where they know who came up with that shit?
I want,
speaking of,
uh,
of which I'm already going into football withdrawal.
I don't know if other NFL fans have this,
there's always that amazing excitement when the NFL playoffs are coming up.
But then there's also like that depression of like,
fuck,
it's almost over.
You know,
I hate that like the NFL season,
just cause you know,
one game of fucking weak,
how quick it goes.
Um,
and also secondly,
uh,
I think I'm going to try to get into,
into the,
uh,
the English premiere league soccer.
I found out that I have a channel that actually shows that shit and baseball's
coming up and I'm not,
I just,
I'm just not into fucking watching.
They've red sox angels and Yankees battle it out yet it for the 90th year and a
fucking row.
Um,
so if anybody can it over in England and tell me when that leak starts,
when the playoffs are,
does it overlap in the baseball because that would be fucking phenomenal.
Um,
all right.
So anyways,
let's,
let's get back to this,
uh,
this stuff.
So yeah.
So that's how I look at it.
Okay.
The same way,
you know,
at some point you have to stop.
Yeah.
You got to stop blaming your parents.
She got to stop being like,
dude,
chicks are psychos.
You gotta be like,
no,
I'm picking Psychos and you've got to take responsibility.
I feel the same way about religion.
Do you know what I mean?
If you're a kid or whatever,
and you're young,
right through your 20s,
you believe,
but at some point you got to understand it's a fucking guests.
And that is an unbelievably profitable fucking business,
you
know?
I mean,
especially,
you know,
that shit that they say a rich man has as much chance as getting into heaven as
a camel has walking through the eye of a needle and you look at how these
fucking people in your religion or live in a,
then they don't seem too concerned about getting through the eye of that fucking
needle.
You know,
wake the fuck up.
People go buy a $19 gold coin yet Jesus all right?
And not trying to be judged,
whatever.
Maybe,
maybe I don't understand it.
Um,
all right,
next one.
Um,
it was actually,
you know what?
There was somebody who actually had a real rational point here that I wanted to
read.
Uh,
alright.
And it's entitled for what it's worth,
you know,
at first of all,
right there.
That's what the Internet needs a little more of,
you know,
for what it's worth rather than being like,
hey shithead like I do.
Oh Great.
Um,
all right bill,
just want to say I understand your points on the religious thing.
Like us raised Catholic and left at this point.
I actually recently started going back to Christian Church that doesn't have a
denomination.
It's not bad or anything.
It's just playing Christian.
Anyway.
I totally agree with you when it comes down to the fact that people don't really
know and the whole idea is full of holes.
I think the biggest problem is that Christians love to get into debates only
bringing the faith concept along,
which obviously makes no sense to people that haven't bought into the whole
idea,
which makes the whole argument pointless.
Exactly.
Um,
and that's the problem with Christians,
just like other groups of people.
A lot of them are frankly stupid and don't know what they're talking about.
It's not really their fault.
Just not everyone is meant to teach others on every topic.
All right?
You know,
I don't know if I agree with that.
No,
it is your fault.
If you're a fucking idiot,
why?
If you're born stupid,
you know that's not your fault.
But,
uh,
if you're just a fucking moron who repeats shit that people say in bars like me.
All right,
why don't we shut the fuck up and read the rest of this?
Bill,
I think something you could understand is no one buys into the Christian thing
just because of the Bible.
If they do,
they probably can be won over by anything.
People buy into the Christian thing because of something they felt that that is
beyond understanding.
After feeling it,
they start looking for an answer and they are drawn into the Christian thing.
At that point,
you can just feel it in your bones and you know it's real,
but it's a personal experience for everyone and it can't be taught.
But I think what that guy meant by asked Jesus and tell you is not literally
ask.
I knew we didn't mean that I was just being an asshole.
It's really a soul search,
which isn't something that usually happens overnight and eventually you will
come to an understanding within yourself.
Uh,
reading the Bible going to church can help,
but it all comes down to whether you are even interested to finding out,
I mean right there,
I 100% agree with all of that.
Okay.
And I like to think that I made some sort of point where I,
I guess I believe in some sort of higher thing because you can feel,
I know it's inexplicably,
but I also know that nobody alive knows what the like,
I feel that that,
that feeling that you're talking about,
I feel as a private thing and it shouldn't be exploited and it shouldn't be this
moneymaking thing and you shouldn't try to scare the shit out of me that I'm
going to hell and all this stuff and start making up all these fucking cartoon
characters like they have.
You know what I mean?
That's what they're doing.
They're just making up shit and they're making up stories and all this fucking
crap based off of this feeling and also based off of people's fear of dying.
But I,
I have to 100% agree with all that.
I mean,
see,
that's the way you go about it.
Okay?
For what it's worth.
The mere fact that he puts in for what it's worth is right there.
It's like,
okay,
I'm not ramming this shit down your throat for what it's worth.
This is what I feel.
No point did he say he's 100% right.
This is just how we feel.
Okay?
That's the way to go about it.
As opposed to these other person who,
this is what somebody wrote me,
Bill,
there's an empty spot inside of you that you try to fill with anything you can
fame hitting it,
big fortune,
family,
dog,
et Cetera.
But actually there isn't anything that can fill that void and that empty void
fill that void,
empty feeling inside you except for a GE says,
Aye.
I mean,
that is the funniest fucking thing ever.
They're trying to convince me that I'm not happy.
This is like the happiest period of my life.
I got a great girl.
I'm living with her.
I love her.
I love living with there.
I got a fucking dog.
I mean,
how great my life is to come home to them.
It's great.
It's fucking great.
My career is right where it's at.
I've carved out a nice niche for myself.
People show up.
I got a cool level of notoriety,
but I could still walk down the street with no pants on and no one would give a
shit short of why is this guy not wearing pants and having a great fucking time
and this person is super imposing their own feeling of when they accepted Jesus
because they couldn't fill it up with shit that now they're going to tell me
that I'm empty and they don't even fucking know me moron.
So anyways,
the only way to fail it up,
he has to come to our church and do except Jesus and the reaching your pocket,
take out that legal tender,
put it in the basket,
gave them to me.
I'll go gain a hooker and we'll be out again next Sunday.
Um,
he actually made that spot inside of you.
Okay?
Let's,
this is how,
this is how fucking you guys into science fiction.
All you guys who can't afford movie tickets because of the recession and you're
really killing yourself because you can't go see Avatar.
I got one for you here.
Just sit back,
close your eyes,
take a hit off something if need to.
Here's the rest of this shit.
He actually made that spot inside of you.
Uh,
that only he fits into crepey.
Um,
really so he wants to get inside of me and that spot then only he fits into
Jesus Christ.
And all you have to do is ask,
you know,
I don't want to ask some dead fucking hippie to crawl into a space inside me.
They don't,
he only fits into,
he's knocking at the door of your heart.
SORTA guy.
I'm not making this up.
Is this lyrics to a bad Jim Nabors song written by John Denver,
Sergeant Carter.
Anyways,
uh,
you only have to open the door because he's a gentleman.
He won't force his way in.
He will come in if invited.
He's waiting patiently.
But is it?
But,
but,
and this is from me to you.
There's no time like the present.
Nobody knows how long anybody lives.
It says in the Bible also tomorrow is promised to no one but don't get spooked.
Oh yeah.
Why would I want to get spooked when you telling me,
you know,
tomorrow isn't promised to anybody and this is dead fucking son of this dude who
was stuck at a vagina without any seaman who wants to get inside me into a space
that only he fits into
a but though get spoke to doesn't mean as soon as you do that it's curtains.
No,
I'm not saying,
Oh you,
this guy are the worst.
I can't even read the rest of that shit is just fucking ridiculous,
dude.
You don't want,
you're doing right now.
It's like you went down to the car dealership and they sold you a lemon and now
you want to dump it onto me.
And you're trying to remember the horrible sales pitch that they gave to you.
Come on in here.
Or are you tired?
Are you weak?
Are you,
are you broke?
How many people out there?
I could fucking do that.
Jesus Christ.
Here I am trying to blow up telling jokes.
Why don't I just start my own fucking church?
Okay.
You know who else?
Who else there has been tired this week and what you do is you have your hand up
the whole time.
Who not?
There's been tired.
Let me hear you say how tired.
What?
Jesus wants you to be tired.
He wants you to be tired of living the life you're living
staff.
You'd wake up against a man energy.
Reach into your fucking pockets of I want when I want to curse in my church.
Is she a fucking pockets?
Gimme some goddamn money you guys want to.
Who here wants to feel better?
Would you guys go to a church if I just talk like this?
I used to do that stupid sing stuff.
Stopping my foot wearing a fucking sky blue.
Three three piece fucking suit.
Now would you go to my church if I did that?
Okay.
Yeah.
Whoever wants to feel better.
All right.
What do you want to do this year,
sir?
You want to lose some weight but you're going to lose weight?
Yeah,
you can do it.
Stop being a pussy.
He chicken breasts and fucking Broccoli at seven o'clock.
Go to bed.
Drinks of fucking water.
All right.
That'll be five bucks.
Ass Off.
I don't even want to fuck.
I'm going with this already.
Getting self conscious and I'm gonna start screaming again.
Don't worry.
The podcast will be fine.
I just got to let this,
I got to look to shit.
Die Down with fucking uh,
okay.
I don't know that guy.
I played Mr Hand and fast times at Ridgemont high.
He's dead now,
isn't he?
All right.
Um,
all right,
let's plow ahead.
Okay
Dude.
Like he can't believe all this shit I got,
I got another guy who actually,
um,
he was saying that he thought the podcast was hilarious and all this stuff they
sent in religion was really funny.
And then he tried to get me to read the book of Mormon
and I was real sneaky.
And he's,
you know,
his selling points where also I,
I don't want to read it.
I don't want to,
I've been to Utah.
I've seen what your religion does to people.
Okay.
I've been there,
I've seen it.
Everybody sneaking around fucking the girlfriend in the ass.
So she's still a Goddamn Virgin,
you know,
32 year old guys still walking around.
Never had a piece of ass in their fucking life because some guys got 58 wives
told them not to.
I mean,
I don't know what to tell you.
I'm not trying to shit on Utah.
All right.
Beautiful scenery.
Okay.
But you only get one life.
Go down to the drug store,
get some condoms and start talking shit.
All right.
That's what the fuck you supposed to be doing and your teens in your 20s okay.
And then eventually one day you're going to be fucking a girl that you don't
give a shit about.
You're going to roll over and you're going to feel this empty feeling.
And you'd be like,
what the fuck am I doing?
I can't do this anymore.
Oh my God.
She really going to try to have some false sense of intimacy.
Now.
Isn't that the worst?
That's why I always hated about one night stands was afterwards.
I always loved those professional girls who just got the fuck out afterwards.
Not trying to,
you know,
suppress any sort of a guilt,
any sort of guilt.
That's the worst one night stand is when that fucking creepy hand comes over and
you know,
she puts her head onto your chest
and their fucking hair and he's just sitting there.
I remember Billy Crystal and,
and uh,
when Harry met Sally and he's got that one foot on his floor and his eyes are
wide awake.
Yeah.
At some point you get sick of that and he's just like,
all right,
you know,
if I don't fucking settle down and get a good one,
I'm up like that fucking grumpy old man downstairs.
Uh,
all right.
Somebody's trash me on my ignorance on the NFL network,
you said,
I'm surprised it's such a big fortune.
A sports fan is Jesus Christ.
Do you see emails?
I guess first of all,
let me say that I am surprised that such a big sports fan as you is confused by
the NFL network and Nfl Sunday ticket.
The Sunday ticket is the exclusive offering on directv that gives you every
game.
Every week I realized that I have this so I can watch the eagles in DC and by
the way,
it's amazing.
It's like sports having,
I can't imagine not having it.
I understand now the NFL is just a single channel that is also on direct TV and
as a frequent toot,
I understand all of this.
Okay.
I have cable.
It's not available for me out here.
Okay.
In order for me to get it,
I have to sign up with direct TV and they wanted me to sign like a three year
contract with a cable service that I've never seen before or used for.
All I know they suck.
Okay.
I was giving him shit.
I understand their business.
I have no problem paying for the NFL ticket.
I would buy it if it was on cable.
All right.
But I can't put addition to the side of my fucking building.
I can't,
my landlord does not allow it.
All right?
So,
and I understand that they have good matchups and they show them on Thursday as
a way to entice me into,
uh,
and to fucking,
you know,
buying the network.
I get it.
It's fucking business.
But Dude,
you know,
to blackout of game on Christmas is a corporate conti fucking mood and you,
you,
you're fucking with people's holidays,
you know,
show me the Goddamn game.
Take one day off.
You know?
That's all I was fucking saying.
Okay.
I understand the whole concept
because explaining the NFL network to me,
I don't understand that.
Oh,
really?
Did you enjoy watching your fucking eagles today?
Get pounded by the,
the,
the goddamn cowboys man.
What a what a rough week in Philly.
Huh?
What a rough month.
They lose cliff Lee.
They get trashed by the God damn cowboys and,
uh,
they lose the winter classic to my Bruins in overtime.
I got to met dude.
Nobody takes over a stadium like Philly fans.
Did.
Anybody watched that?
It was the sound,
like it was a fucking home game for the flyers.
Really disappointed with Bruins fans,
but you know what,
tickets was so much.
It was the fucking rich people there anyways,
and then we're going to do anything.
Um,
but still I got to give it up for the fucking Philly's fan.
Uh,
Philadelphia fans.
All right.
That might be the end of the podcast.
One of my 49 whispering minutes into this thing.
Um,
anyways,
I dunno,
this is my deal.
I think when it comes down to that whole God thing,
I think that's a personal fucking journey and I'm not working on it at all.
So what I'm really doing is just blown off church,
but I'm never going to go back to church anyways,
but I'll,
I'll,
I have to,
I have to start living by some sort of a fucking code
because,
uh,
because I'm not,
you know,
and when you become an adult and you don't have parents anymore,
I mean,
as long as you're not breaking the law,
you can pretty much do a lot of scumbag things.
And then one really calls you on it.
And,
uh,
you know,
pass it out in the second quarter of a fucking Rose Ball.
What a loser.
What a fucking loser.
Um,
anyways,
what else do I got here?
I just got sorta like fucking this is like holiday leftovers,
this podcast.
Uh,
last week I was talking about some girl who was too dumb to fuck and somebody
really latched onto that.
At that time my buddy was hanging out with that girl who thought the sun and the
moon were the same thing.
And I was saying like,
you have to get with a girl who is so stupid.
Like you can't have sex with her because it feels like a form of rape.
Ah,
fuck.
Anyways,
this guy said,
hey bill,
I love the podcast,
but now it felt compelled to write you until you mentioned the story about the
chick who didn't know the mood and the sun with two different stories and too
dumb to fuck you.
The first guy I ever heard mentioned that I cannot agree with you more.
I have a too dumb to fuck story.
Okay.
I think we have a new segment here.
Um,
here we go.
This is this guy's story about meeting a girl who was too dumb to fuck.
He said,
uh,
when I got out of college,
I was doing the traditional stint in the restaurant serving industry.
Uh,
there was this smoking hot 19 year old waitress working there that every do I
sound like creepy right now cause I'm kind wished for anything.
It was a slogan fucking 19 year old waitress and he's creeping up of working uh,
there that every dude and at least one other girl was trying to get a piece of
bill.
This girl wasn't legitimate 10.
Anyway,
we were at a party one night and I was spending all my time with,
they're listening to a talk about all sorts of nonsense,
trying to be the nice guy trying to get some play right.
You put in your time at,
so anyways,
he said,
well,
the booze was kicking in and uh,
things were starting to work out.
Uh,
we started kissing a bit.
Thanks for looking promising,
but uh,
I knew it would be some time before I get anywhere worthwhile.
I don't know why you would think that,
dude,
you should have closed the fucking deal.
Um,
he said I was w that's classic to do.
You know what I would've done?
I would've fucked her right there.
Um,
I was willing to put in the time.
All right,
so anyways,
a little later in the night she started talking about a rabbit she had when she
was younger and she was subset that her rabbit never laid eggs.
Okay.
Have you ever heard of something so stupid?
If ever heard something so stupid you can't believe you've heard it correctly?
I can not.
Oh man,
that must have been fucking hilarious.
Cause I'm sure there was music playing.
I'm sure you did.
Like,
like we're like what?
And it's sort of like put your ear all at one was inside of her mouth to make
sure you fucking heard of ray.
He goes,
I cannot believe my ears.
So I questioned her only to have her re repeat the claim with even more vigor.
I had a rather,
it did even lay eggs.
My childhood was so difficult.
Did you buy me another drink?
Um,
I shit you not bill.
She was dead serious.
If that was not bad enough.
She argued with me for 15 fucking minutes telling me that rabbits laid eggs and
her proof to this was wait.
No.
He says wait for it.
If rabbits don't lay eggs and why does the Easter,
well then why does Easter have the Easter bunny and Easter eggs?
Wow.
This girl really took that Cadbury egg fucking story to heart from that point
on.
This girls 10 status dropped by a half.
I cannot even think about fucking this girl anymore.
To this day.
She's probably still so good looking that no dude ever told her that she was
wrong.
So he could just get in her pants and she's probably still tasting rabbit
pellets hoping for m and m's like,
yeah,
dude,
I that's,
that's a,
that's a strong fucking movie.
Your Age,
your age.
I probably would have still plowed through.
I don't,
I dunno.
I,
I always had that man.
I always had that thing that if I did not connect with somebody,
I do know something.
I tried to do what most guys do that basically,
you know,
fuck anything that moves and then they come back and they tell the horrific
story.
And uh,
I was never able to do that.
If I,
if there was like no connection,
like I've just never been able to,
uh,
oh,
that's a bullshit.
I got a couple in there.
I got a couple of Nice.
That's right.
Oh Jesus.
Am I going to tell this?
I can't fuck it.
Tell this story.
Okay.
Here we go.
You know what?
This is just bills a piece of shit.
Wake.
Okay.
Uh,
yeah,
I got,
I didn't yell at the old guy,
you know,
the guy I was so,
what is,
I'm so upset with it or how that all guy thing meant that actually feel like I
yelled at him and I didn't even yell at him.
He's fucking yelling at me.
Um,
all right.
So I had the old guy incident.
I passed out during the second fucking
quarter of the granddaddy of them off and a,
okay,
here's this story.
Uh,
early on in my life I rode career.
I was like,
I dunno,
I dunno how fuck Jesus Christ,
they have fat.
Fuck just sold them.
I love that when football players run into those fat guys who like their job is
to hold like that sound thing for the NFL films.
Um,
you know,
they feel that for weeks to anyways.
Um,
all right,
here's the story.
I think it was about 30 years old and,
uh,
I was doing this club and uh,
I was in this bar and the Jello shot girl comes by,
you know the Jello shot girl is always like fucking smoking hot,
you know,
she has to be,
she's selling Jello.
Do you want to do a Jello shot?
No,
nobody does.
They just want to talk to you with your fucking ass and titties.
So this girl looked like a fucking Barbie doll.
Right?
He had a fucking ass.
Teddy's blonde hair,
just fucking gorgeous.
Right?
So,
uh,
I don't know what to Fau.
I remember what happened.
I did the classic when I had fucking zero game with women.
I just invited her out to a show working uncle fuckees down the street.
And I got,
I like that age out.
So anyway,
she shows up the next night with a friend,
you know,
looking even better and uh,
Yada,
Yada.
Long story short,
at the end of the fucking night,
and when she showed up with like four other girls,
which was automatically a fucking problem,
but this girl was like,
she was raring to go.
I mean,
she sat down on my lap within fucking 10 minutes,
so I'm trying to get out of there,
but at a friend's keep fucking cock blocking me.
So long story short,
the night ends were in a parking garage.
All right.
I'm 30.
She's like fucking 18,
by the way.
19 maybe.
So I look like I'm fucking 106.
So,
uh,
all of her friends,
wait a minute,
she couldn't have been that young because she was serving Jello shots.
Was She 21?
Maybe I was like 32,
33.
I can't remember.
It's all fucking run together.
Whatever.
I was too fucking old to be with this girl.
Let's put it that way.
So,
um,
they're fucking,
uh,
it's the end of the night.
Okay.
And we're in the parking garage in a friends are telling her to get in the car
and she's like,
Nah,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna that back and go home with this guy.
And they go,
that's cool.
Just come over here and talk for a second.
And she walked over to the car and she sticks her head in the window and for,
I swear to God,
10 minutes,
they're trying to talk her out of not leaving with this creepy older guy.
And I'm standing there like an asshole.
And I was standing there for so long,
I started rooting for the girls in the car.
I'm like,
yeah,
come on and talk her out of it.
She shouldn't be here with me.
And of course they fucking didn't.
And uh,
you know,
and that you go and that's the podcast for the weekend.
I did pour all my booze down the fucking sink except for the last bottle of
Scotch.
Alright,
go fuck yourself.
What am I a saint?
Maybe I do need Jesus.
All right,
you guys have a great week.
And I,
I'm saying that jokingly,
right?
You fucking maniacs who keep emailing me.
Trying to get me into,
Gee,
I'm not into the guy.
All right.
Put a fucking shirt on and stop complaining.
Your father gave you the fucking ability to walk on water,
flowed off the fucking cross.
I didn't ask you to die for me.
All right.
You fucking martyr.
Um,
that's it.
Everybody have a great God damn week and,
uh,
that's it.
Happy New Year
and hope you guys all have something
[inaudible].